we have some new tour dates and these
are some new ones Memphis Tennessee
we've added a show August 4th and 5th at
the cannon Center for the Performing
Arts
um I know the Chattanooga show sold out
don't worry uh don't go get a fancy
price ticket we will come back
um and you'll have another opportunity
Toronto Ontario uh August 30th and 8th
show added in Toronto San Jose
California we've added a second show
September 14th
uh and 13th Oakland California
September 16th at the Paramount Akron
Ohio we've added a show
um on the 8th or 7th Washington D.C
we've added a show October 19th and 20th
if your city is sold out just keep an
eye out we'll come back through we also
have some tickets left for Windsor
Ontario on August 18th
get your tickets through theovan.com
t-o-u-r and thank you so much for coming
out and supporting the return of the Rat
tour
today's guest is an iconic uh comedian
uh actor I watched one of his movies not
long ago it's so good
um this is the second time on the
podcast he's out of Indiana
and he has a new special coming out on
Amazon next week called Dark pale
he has a new television series too you
can check out called Full Circle on Max
I'm grateful to chop it up with my buddy
today Mr Jim Gaffigan
[Music]
and are you
[Applause]
I don't know what you're you know if
you're with a podcasting thing or but
it's like the impact see that looks
better bro yeah that looks nice I'm a
good looking guy I yeah well
so does it feel like you're getting
crazy like the podcast is getting busier
yeah yeah it feels like it's getting
busier I feel like we've been
really lucky
I think we're independent too since we
don't work with a network
I think that people like that what is
the
what makes you connect
with people
I mean it's the every man thing but it's
also like is there
another you know authenticity people
crave that right yeah maybe they do I
think they probably do especially these
days you know yeah I think we want to
try and I mean yeah if I hear something
that seems
that's real or somebody's talking about
something that's a mean something to
them I think it means a lot uh yeah I
don't know why we've been really
fortunate I you know
um
yeah we've had we've gotten to have some
unique guests I think
you know I've always enjoyed talking all
different types of people you know I
think I'm I'm a late learner kind of you
know some podcasters they have a lot of
information right I don't have it
right but I am curious about a lot of
stuff curiosity is key right yeah yeah
and I think I want to learn still you
know yeah you look but you look handsome
man oh thank you what's the most
handsome you've ever felt in your life
you ever think about that like was there
ever uh that's a very good question
um you know as a male model I struggle
with it no I don't think I've ever
really
felt particularly handsome I always seem
to look at pictures from the past and go
oh that was I should have been happier
yeah right
yeah I you know and I my you know having
teenagers you know it's so brutal being
a teenager and I'm like dude you got a
good you know but your metabolism's
working still yeah you can yeah you can
have a pint of ice cream it's not
doesn't make a dent your dexterity yeah
your hair health is even your hair is
strong you know like we you know like
you don't have a mustache yet they don't
they don't hear
like when people like aches and pains
they don't have aches and pains really
not a chance but I don't know I never
really I never really
felt particularly good looking I feel
like I've never been
that's never been an asset
how about you I you seem like I feel
like ignored in a like a Nordic area you
would have ve you would be a
I could see you being a like a like
Hasselhoff and sweep me
no no
I like yeah that's very kind of like a
Nordic kind of mountain model
there is
there you know like among comedians
there is like there is this strange
thing where I think
uh some comedians get embraced as being
attractive
but I don't think that's in my that's
not a
theoretical thing that you know like
Steve Carell like I think there was like
this is just maybe me you know getting
it from Twitter but you know women were
like Steve Corral you know it's like I'm
like Steve Carell yeah that's and so you
see that coming yeah but I don't think
that's that's not in the the likelihood
or the possibility for me what about
like in the 1700s or something
foreign
like was there a time period you think
because I I mean I think I think you're
a handsome your height you're tall so
that gives you some handsome well pale
you know and then there was the
reubeness period like oh yeah you know
like being uh being pudgy means that
you're not poor and being pale means
that you're not working in the field but
I don't think that's been real you'd
have been the rock dude in the 1600s
1600s I would have been people would
have been there would have been posters
I mean they all would have been drawn
they're like did you see how how pale
and fat that guy is oh my God that he's
beautiful he's so hot is that Emily
radakowski right I would be like the
male radakowski yeah of
think about like the Breakthrough
I mean there's so many beautiful women
but Emily Ratajkowski like you brought
that up I knew exactly what you mean
what is it about her and how long have
you been dating her yeah because it's
not out of the possibilities I'm a
married man but I don't know you could
date her I don't get Emily Ratajkowski I
get you don't get you don't get it you
don't I get that she's pretty yeah I get
that yeah she looks pretty to me but I
don't get hit on by that type of gal no
no I get uh
who do I get well let me let's put it
out there I get a lot of like people
like you know kind of rural women right
send me like a nude picture kind of be
like a drive out here and eat this
they'll say stuff like that because
they're ladies right good point and
they're but they're like they're it
sounds like it involves some travel yeah
well it's out travel a lot of them are
outside of the city limits it's a
connecting flight too which is like
you're like you know
but you know I'm kind of uh
I'm kind of a Suburban rural guy too
yeah you're I mean so like
I think and I don't know if we talked
about this last time but like there is
something of
I mean look I love I live in New York
and I've lived in New York for 30 years
but like when I like these different
markets you know uh these cities are
smaller towns like
I have I have a good time there like
when I hang out in Cedar Rapids
I'm like
and I'll go to a restaurant I'm like
yeah this is
this feels very familiar and like once
you pie first sir no no but do you know
what I'm saying oh yeah it's like a
steakhouse in Cedar Rapids yeah that's
I prefer that than a super fancy
restaurant in New York or L.A yeah it's
a good point man I think I do too I
think you feel more at ease more
comfortable more likely to see a fight I
feel like there's more
you know somebody will come over and say
they they like your blouse or your shirt
or something you can wear an apron in
there and people don't look at you weird
yeah you know like there is like if a
guy no one's in
uh an outfit like that's right like if
so no one's kind of dressing
uh like Eddie Vedder yeah they they
dress like that even yeah do you know
what I mean
yeah yeah yeah and yes you'll see the
most beautiful women oh God beautiful
like you ever been to like let's come on
Santo dude Monsanto will preserve a babe
you know what I'm saying you get some of
those field names those Daughters of
farm hands brother uh what I I just
think of like times when I you know I've
been on bus tours with my family and
we'll go horseback riding and there will
be just like working at some horse ranch
the most beautiful woman in the world
and you know she probably sleeps with
the horses and she smells like the
horses but not an ounce of makeup on her
and she's better looking than any woman
in the city yeah
anyway I'm a great guy I don't know if I
brought that up yeah no I think look
it's you seem like a great guy and I
think it's um
yeah it's interesting I think the like
view like how we feel beauty how we feel
if we're handsome I think it's
interesting because I'll look at old
pictures of myself as well and be like
man
you had a chance with girls you didn't
think you had any chance in the world
right but you had it you were or you
just thought so lowly of yourself but
man you were doing good yeah no I wasted
the time that's what I feel like
sometimes I go back on it well I think
there's uh anxiety
uh and you know there's the chemicals
racing through you when you're a
teenager it's hard by the way I think
you know having a couple teams I think
it's way harder to be a teenager now
than it was it really oh
brutal so when we went to high school
we were compared to this pool of people
in our school
I mean kids today they're compared to
everyone on social media it's brutal oh
that's true I never thought about that
and so like also the adventures that we
would go on to like
find you know mushrooms wheat or or
pornography oh it was an adventure and
now it's kind of thrust on these kids
and so
you know I'm sure there's scientific
explanation but it's almost like you
know you had to go on a scavenger hunt
to even get in trouble
uh at least for me right so there was a
journey to it too yeah you know whereas
now it's
it's you know you you know it's pretty
easy you can get it delivered now you
know what I mean yeah and that's
great when you're 30 40 but like when
you're 15 or 18 it's like
it's almost too easy to get weed now
oh yeah it's too easy to get a high it's
too easy to get anything I mean armor
with pornography we had this dude in our
neighborhood names they called him
Skittle was his nickname and he was like
um
impaired or whatever yeah you know he
had impairment well what kind of
impairment he didn't have uh his legs
didn't work yeah so it was in oh he was
he was handicapped he was bipedal or
whatever what is that called
paraplegic paraplegic yeah this para so
like just his like was he in a
wheelchair yeah he was in a wheelchair
but sometimes they would and then at the
video store they would his like uh
Handler or whatever it was his cousin
would push would like get him out and
let him crawl under the uh into the
nudie room in there oh that's nice and
people would be I mean you would kind of
because you knew he was probably
and I hate to say that she knew he was
never going to mate in his life right
probably but people would be so excited
you know they'd be like Skittles in the
nudie rooms you know and and was he
called skills because he enjoyed the
candy Skittles or I don't know that's a
good question I think he uh he said from
what I think he liked all candies I
remember but he just
yeah people I don't know there was just
something excited about him people be
like oh Skittles in the nudie room and
people would be so excited it's so
amazing how there was a nudity room
there was there was I mean the the
Blockbuster was just kind of like Hey
we're not gonna have that yeah we don't
believe in that but like the off kind of
like the independent stores there would
be
uh there would be kind of like movie you
know like regular movies and then there
would be like the the r rateds i mean
the the kind of like naughty stuff and
you would have to like
if you would go even as a you know a
teenager or like in your 20s and you had
curiosity you needed a reason to go over
there right you needed like hey why
don't we go over here just to check it
out like you couldn't be like you
couldn't go in and make a beeline for it
yeah yeah you had to be like this is so
silly what's this stuff oh my gosh
what's this yeah are they selling
cigarettes yeah what is it what is this
oh this is gross
but now a kid just turns on I mean by
the way Twitter like I don't know if you
get this Twitter's very dangerous it's
like there's like just I don't know open
the pictures just because I'm a
Christian yeah but uh there's like they
said this the spam or the robots send
you pornography it's insane and you're
like
you know I'm trying to like because you
know you you go through a process I
think uh most men where you're like all
right I'm going to set some boundaries
there's nothing too productive
and consuming pornography so I'm gonna
I'm gonna set up some boundaries or some
barriers but like when it's thrown at
you yeah and why are robots doing that
that makes me believe even more like in
UFOs and people are like yeah they took
me somewhere yeah and put something in
my butt and they dropped me back off
like it's always they're always putting
stuff in people's butts too and they
yeah but and at first I'm like are they
would they really do that but then now
that I see that these otherwise are just
emailing people like it's
you know these like these Bots or
whatever like email and porn to people
it's like obviously these these aliens
are pervert I don't even I don't know if
it's aliens but I don't know what I mean
I guess I've never clicked on it but
like
it's I guess it's to get you to watch
their porn right yeah
yeah I think different people want you
like come over here step right up you
know yeah well guess how much Siemens in
you you know we'll guess that you know
your weight in semen or whatever when I
was a teenager I thought you had a
limited Supply I thought you could run
out
oh dude I the first
erection ever got it was coming up and I
thought it was a like a poop in my body
that it was going the wrong way
that's a that's a normal response and I
really thought it was a poop yeah it was
so scary because it was the same shape
and I was like oh my god dude I one of
my poops is lost I mean even like it's
just so it was so scary remember your
body growing and people thought it would
grow forever I had a buddy who got so
scared he thought his his whole body
would grow into a wiener and like there
would be nothing left of him and then
the wiener would grow and then it would
go back and he would reform yeah I just
remember having leg spasms
and and did your nipples hurt yeah
remember that no one talked you about it
yeah well you know when I was growing up
no one talked to you about any of that
stuff
you know there was just like
there was just you had to figure it out
and I thought I was mentally ill I mean
I am mental ill but like I thought oh my
God you know I'm like
the biggest pervert in the world and the
reality is I was just like a 15 year old
boy yes you know what I mean no one was
like hey
because I've kind of done that I'm like
look hey it's it doesn't mean you're a
bad person it just means I'm not saying
engage in it you know I'm not saying Go
full animal
uh you know even though some people do
but like
you know it doesn't mean you're a bad
person yeah it's true that you yeah I
think in the past it's there's been a
lot of that energy like something
there's something wrong with you yeah
like if you walked up to a monkey at the
zoo because monkeys they say some of the
monkeys will uh masturbate and stuff six
to seven times a day at the zoo so if
you if you saw somebody walk in there to
one of them and be like you know sit
them down in the chair on the side of
the shame man yeah say you're filthy
yeah you're filthy you're not behaving
like an animal yeah
you'd be like that person's crazy for
saying that to that monkey right
or or there'll probably be some people
that are like finally someone's telling
that monkey stop doing that it's all
relative right and then there's people
that would be like I can't believe that
you're judging that monkey's Behavior do
you know what I mean yeah there'll be
somebody else being like that monkey can
choose its own pronouns and be like it's
not about that okay it's just jerking
off too much and you know there's that
and then there's also throwing the the
the shed yeah they throw there yeah they
throw a lot of anything comes out of
their body they're willing to throw it
why do we I feel like it's like Mardi
Gras we have you know but there's no
beads right you know like if they or
maybe that's their beads right yeah
they're just throwing that out they're
naked all the way like it's it's not
like they're even flashing because like
supposedly if you flash then
to get the beads but the problem was
that Mardi Gras and I'll say this man is
that the breasts you saw were good or
bad they were not good right they were
drunk they look like some of them had
been drinking like the breast alone had
been drinking right by itself even some
of them yeah
um they uh that's another problem with
pornography is we set up false
expectations of what breasts are
supposed to look like yeah that's
another reason not to watch porn
right well you've kind of gone again I
mean I'm sure you've seen in your
lifetime where breasts fake breasts
really popped off do you remember the
first time you're like wow they're
putting in
yeah there was a yeah I mean the I don't
know I'm kind of like I'm not a huge
like there's there's part of me that's
the whole huge breast thing it doesn't
it's weird you know like
for me it doesn't do anything you know I
mean and some guys like big breasts some
guys like like big butts I'm kind of you
know I like
yeah I like I like
shape but I don't like
and and it's a mystery to me because
some guys really like
big butts some guys really like I
remember when I first started stand up I
was doing some Road gag and this
headliner was like here I want to show
you something and he showed me and it
was a Polaroid of him with a woman that
had like enormous like gigantic and he
was he was kind of bragging he's like
see
see see who I met and I was like this is
what's head this is what you're headed
towards I was like you play your card
and I wanted to be polite and I was
polite but I was like that's you know
like that's obviously she needs help
yeah I mean but like and I didn't want
to rain on his parade but he was like
yeah
that's what got him off that was like he
was I'm sure he probably still has that
Polaroid yeah like maybe if he was maybe
when he dies he's buried with the
Polaroid of the woman with the gigantic
boobs some guys it's interesting how
that's all they care about boy they're
looking amazing different taste
yeah I think well they started to get
we yeah some of the boobs started to
look like somebody had filled up a glad
bag too big you know you ever have that
one somebody pulls a black Glide bag out
of a like at a restaurant when they're
doing the dumpster they went there and
they pull the bag out of that can and
it's way too heavy for the bag you know
and it's not gonna make it and there's
there's liquids
there's liquid dripping out and you're
like that's gonna that's gonna be a mess
yeah
that's just gonna be a mess it's just
it's weird I need to know all right so
uh you're you're in though are you a big
boob guy or a little like if you tell me
you're like I like enormous boobs I
wouldn't be shocked and I don't mean
that as an insult no it's fine but like
are you a big boob guy are you a big
butt guy I think I'm more of probably a
um
I think I like them you know a more I
think I'm more of probably a mid-range I
like a little bit of buttocks yeah you
know I like a woman that's healthy
enough to conceive right right you know
I don't like
um
I'm not into those kind of needle Army
looking you know the kind of girls who
looked a little bit too weathered yeah
you know like I need a woman that's
healthy enough to be able to have a
family right so I think that's a big
thing for me
um
you know there was a
what was the question you asked me it
was about like a types of web because
here I'll bring this up my brother
um
uh one of his he really he liked a woman
that looked good in a baseball cap and a
turtleneck which I thought was really
interesting
and
um I mean that's a setup for a joke he's
you know like now he's like a serial
killer right no but like but it is
interesting he really like if she looked
cute in a baseball cap
he he was like she looks good yeah she's
she's great yeah and so like there's
different things there's types right
that's a good point there's different
scenarios you want your woman to look
good in kind of
that's that's a really good point right
it's kind of like you know I remember
when I was
considering asking my wife to marry me I
was like you know what I could have fun
folding laundry with her I mean now we
hate each other but at the time
we could do you earned that hatred but
no but it is like one of those things
where
it's not just about how they look in a a
small skirt you know I mean it is
about you know and not just like their
fun at uh you know
or something right
but it is interesting
First Impressions matter they do
you know it's important how do you how
do you present yourself
and for me I like to take care of myself
I like to take care of my skin keep my
skin decent
and Men occurred baby that's what I like
to do and I use Caldera lab I use their
regimen
it's called the regimen actually in
Caldera lab creates a high performance
men's skin care product
and the regimen leads off their product
lineup
it's a twice a day routine to transform
your skin God look at his skin I want
some of it
that's right the Caldera lab the bundle
you'll find the skincare Dream Team the
Clean Slate the base layer and the good
they even have an eye serum if you like
that called the icon if you don't like
all that that's fine but if you do
Caldera lab get 20 off with our code
Theo at Caldera lab that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-l-a-b.com that's 20 off at
calderalab.com by using Code Theo jump
into skin and first impression royalty
with Caldera lab so your ideal woman
let's put it out there okay right there
then I would say she has nice eyes like
kind of caring eyes like eyes oh warm
eyes warm eyes yes because that is true
it's important it's important to the
kids too yes definitely you know you
don't want some cold-eyed freaking
Slytherin broad yeah you know making
even serving muffins to your children no
so warm-eyed
um
I would say hard working hard-working
sense of humor is really important yeah
sense of humor or the ability to laugh
even being able to laugh though is also
like having an inverse sense of humor
like if somebody's a good laugher I
think it's just as it's almost better
than it's in humor because at least
they're they're getting they're having
the joy you know by the way the hard
worker thing I think is really key too
yeah yeah my wife is a very hard worker
and that's that's uh that's great
because then you can do less
is I mean I'm we have a similar work
ethic we enjoy working you know what I
mean and I wouldn't say working I I'm
not saying like hey let's go grab some
construction shifts you know it's like
you know uh it's fulfilling for us I
mean yeah and life's hard work it's like
if you want to stay in a marriage it
seems like it's a lot of like if you
really want anything to work you got to
do it you know that's what it seems like
yeah
um how tall how tall I would say
anywhere probably five
six yeah to six one okay and how tall
are you I'm willing to go on the outlier
side with the height I am six foot you
wouldn't care if she was taller I don't
think I would care as long as she didn't
do little things to me like probably Pat
on Like Pat me or something like that
I'll call you shorty yeah yeah yeah
or say hey give me that little wiener
yeah and things like that and what about
uh and what about the do you want her to
be younger than you older than you I
would probably say younger than me you
know I want her to be able to Bear you
know bear children if she wants to yeah
um but then I got to make sure that I'm
in a good space too you know I don't
want to be some philanderer right right
I don't want to be a man who's peeking
over the fence and you know talking to
the neighbor's wife right and I don't
want to be you shouldn't be neighborly
you shouldn't be talking even to a
neighbor
um no but you're saying so you you want
to also be mature you want to be to the
point yeah yeah I don't want to be doing
any more like I don't want to be more do
any more conniving or any like I wanna
you know I just want to be locked in
yeah did you have a point where you were
like was it scary for you when you were
like okay I'm gonna get married this is
it like did you have your mom like who
dropped you off to go ask your wife
would you drive over there how did you
do it I was uh my mom dropped me off no
uh no I uh I was
at my brother's house we'd gone back we
used to go back and we'd go to Indiana
and then we'd drive through Chicago and
go to Milwaukee where my wife's from and
I you know my wife and I we had this
agreement that
she was gonna tell me when she was ready
to be proposed you know because you know
the whole you you don't there's no risk
you don't want them to be like uh no and
you don't want you to process no so and
we had talked about we had dated for a
while and um and I was at my brother's
place and uh we were smoking a cigar in
his garage
and I said you know I tell you if I had
a ring I probably would ask her and he
goes oh I can give you a ring I'll give
you a mom's old ring I used it and you
can use it and I was like oh
and so then you're really on the spot
and I was like this all right but you
know again I had also kind of made that
decision do you know what I mean so the
decision had already been made yeah you
know I mean it wasn't like oh my brother
told me to do it so I did it you know
what I mean so uh and then we went up
there and I knew that I kind of wanted
to surprise her
and so I did it right in front of her
entire family and she's one of nine kids
and we had done opening presents and her
I had asked her dad for permission he
was like cooking in the kitchen and he's
kind of a a great guy but like at that
point we didn't know each other that
well so he was like taking something out
of the oven I was like hey I would like
to ask your daughter and marry me and
he's like yeah okay and so then we were
opening presents and all the presents
had been opened and then I I did it and
it was did you feel nervous did you get
down on one knee it's so well I think as
a comedian there's so many
it's you know there's so many awkward
situations we go in you know where you
have a show where you eat [__] you have
a show where you do okay but you can
tell half the audience thinks you're a
[__] I mean so like it was
it was awkward it was uh it was you know
it was nice but it's
I'm also
you know are these these watershed
moments for me
are uh
they're not nearly as important as like
you know
the the moment where I feel like I
really connected with my wife you know
like my child being born there was you
know it was special but it's not as
special as like you know the time when
you take a walk with them right for me
yeah there's like a real connection yeah
man or like right those are kind of just
built-in tent pole moments that are yeah
almost I don't want to say old-fashioned
they're very important yeah but they
don't but that it's not like uh it
doesn't mean everything I I for me you
know if that's a good point I think it's
a really good point for everybody we put
all these old it's almost like we put
these kind of like tyrannical like
emotional attachments to these moments
even though they're they might not be
there because times have kind of changed
so yeah having a wedding these days
which is really just a huge party that
takes so much planning which is more
about the planning than it is even the
vowels yes and this the unnecessary
stress oh God put on a sangria all these
yeah you know oh my God the bread is
wrong you know it's like who cares yeah
who cares dude right I barely know this
woman who cares that's the only reason
I'm here yes anybody mention that
they should have a vote at weddings like
should we do it or not and people have
to really vote that's funny wouldn't be
a bad idea I mean a silent and because
it's also your loved ones so it's a
really harsh thing and you shouldn't be
able to open it until the next day oh
it's like the vote came in
well it's and it's like a Rotten Tomato
score like as long as we get 18 yeah
that's it but you're like yeah 43 yeah
that's not good but what the audience
score said
a lot of old tropes and misdirected plot
twists but
a lot of people don't believe in me they
think I'm gonna cause this because your
family should have a vote should have a
vote because you're bringing that
genetics into your gene pool well you
know it feels like the family overall
should have a vote well there's also
something that happens where
you I think the you know it's probably
different in different cultures and
different family cultures but you kind
of
get absorbed I think I feel like the men
get kind of absorbed into the the
woman's family yes a much more than uh
the woman getting absorbed into them I
mean obviously there's a good point yeah
and it's so there is something of
you know like when you're dating someone
and you meet their parents you're like
okay so this is this is the future right
in some ways but also their relationship
and my wife's mother is like a saint and
her dad's a real sweet guy so I was like
all right I'm in good shape it was
totally misleading no but it was fine
dude I had an ex-girlfriend her dad
would always be like hey he would say
like whenever nobody was in the room be
like Hey listen to me he would pass gas
he'd say listen to me fart and then he'd
be like don't tell anybody
wow and he was real serious about it and
it was so strange and I've never even
said anything about it until now but I
just can't believe he even did that who
would yeah that's very strange really
weird I think having like somebody
dating your daughter oh you don't have
any power really no you have no power
and you know I and the kid is a pervert
whoever he is absolutely he's a boy he's
sick he's he's a boy I have a 19 year
old and I have a 14 year old daughter
and so when my 14 year old when she was
13 uh
and she would bring over these guys
and I would try and you know like you
tried different tactics as a dad you're
like I'm gonna be the friend yeah and
you want to get to know them and they're
all you know they're they're boys
they're Liars right and so sick I
remember there was this one kid who
ended up being really sweet and but I
was kind of like
I and I'm kind of like inappropriate I
try to test the boundaries so I'm like
nice to meet you I'd like to
um would you like to see my knife
collection thinking that would be really
intimidating and he's like oh my God I'd
love to see a knife I was like that's
not what I wanted you to say he was like
oh cool you got a knife collection I'm
like no I was trying to frighten you
yeah I mean it's like
but they also know you know you're not
gonna hurt them you know what I mean and
you can't anymore that's one of the
problems too and that's where a lot of
you know a lot of fathers have lost a
lot of their power they used to have the
ability to her to fire a warning shot
into the air yeah
um
and a lot of that's gone yeah I was
thinking about yeah it's so like even
like us what we think about ourselves
how we look like I mean I think a lot of
comedians probably got a lot of males
got into it because they felt it was
their way of gaining attraction from
women did you think so you think yeah I
think so too totally I remember
I remember witnessing
um like I had no confidence at all until
my 30s anyway but I remember I mean I
had it in fits and spurts but
I remember when I started
headlining at a comedy club
and I would stand in the back watching
this is like they didn't have green
rooms or anything like that and I would
stand in the back kind of watching and I
would see people come in and
um there would be you know attractive
women coming in with their friends or
dates or whatever and they would be like
uh who are you know they they didn't
know who I was they didn't care and then
I would do the show
and then those same women
would be treating me completely
differently and intellectually I would
know oh it was the show
they you know they you know they they
think I'm something that I'm not they
think that I'm something special I have
to make a point of never believing the
hype and then after six months I was
like you know what I'm good looking I
kind of totally bought the hype yeah
like so we just get
we're so dumb we're so dumb it's like
it's it's not that I'm on stage and
commanding authority over a crowded room
of 300 people it's because they actually
think I'm good
essentially I'm just a fool you know
what I mean but then some guys who are
not attractive men will their confidence
gets them too attractive absolutely so
it's really part of the trick I think
yeah I even feel like when you look at
remember when you would I don't know if
you'd ever look at a yearbook
and uh or photos of when you were a kid
and you'd see a kid
that you'd be a girl you'd be like oh my
God she was really good looking yeah and
why weren't we why didn't we think
because we didn't because she was
struggling you know what I mean and
didn't have the confidence and whereas
there were girls that were confident
that we were just like because we were
dumb boys we're like duh they think
they're good looking maybe they're good
looking yeah and we would it's so much
of it is confidence and it's like I just
wish as a parent I could just
I you know because my kids are pretty
confident but I just wish that like in
those moments because I remember being a
teenager it's it's hard yeah huh and
people are like just act confident
you're like what are you talking about
yeah I'm filled with anxiety yeah and I
had so dude I remember having acne so
bad do you ever have acne oh I was just
I mean I was this pale kid and whenever
I would talk
and so it was just this goofy guy who
was pale and like you know there it was
I was the palest person anyone had ever
seen so it was but that's probably you
know contributed to me being a comedian
like a dumpling kind of
yeah I was like a marshmallow oh you
know but a marshmallow that would turn
red I was a strawberry flavored
marshmallow
wow dude yeah well it's it's um what's
really interesting is if you think back
to like the beginning of before they had
mirrors and stuff the only way you knew
if you were the way you probably is if
somebody told you how attractive you
were or how handsome or beautiful you
were so that had to be in I bet that's
when like connection was a lot stronger
too between uh people because imagine if
the way you somebody's like you're
beautiful and you've never you don't
have any real thought of that yourself
because you've never seen a reflection
yourself and the way it makes you feel
you're like wow that feeling is so
powerful I feel really connected to this
person yeah now it's like well back then
I mean just imagine how bad did they
smell though but they both smelled bad
they both I guess she got used to it
right I think not having [__] on your
legs was probably like a that means you
were ready to go out on the town because
I feel like that would be something I'm
gonna clean I'ma wash my legs off well
that's what all the cologne and the
perfume was for is to cover up bad smell
the smell of butt yeah you know what I
mean God it's always it'd be so much
nicer if your butt was a little further
away from you right or you could detach
it oh yeah but like I mean showering
like you ever like been on the road and
you're like you have to wear the same
underwear for two days yeah like it's a
crisis and then like and they get warmer
but
but when you're a teenager you don't
care
you don't care at all and but like as an
adult it's also just like the Comfort
level like I used to be able to sleep on
like a bag of rocks and now if I'm like
if I don't have this one pillow in my
arms then the baby can't sleep it's so
ridiculous
yeah man yeah get to know getting older
is interesting what we thought we looked
like when we're younger is interesting
and being it's amazing how much you can
trans pose or share with your children
but how many things you cannot share
it's amazing how many like lessons that
we all go through but we can't there's
no real clean clear way to share that to
a kid so they don't have to deal with
the tragedies of it yeah I mean I uh
they have to
there's so many times when I'm talking
to my kids where I'm like I don't even
know why I'm saying this because it's
like you're not gonna hear it from me
yeah you're gonna have to
go through it it's like even when you're
you know like like kids driving like I'm
sure when you were driving there was
moments where you're like holy cow I
almost ran over that guy yeah do you
know what I mean and it's not like your
parents hadn't said you know you got to
make sure you look but you don't hear
that it's just it's just White Noise
yeah your parents are just yeah
your parents are creepy people you can't
even believe they made they had sex
before yeah it's just gross to think
it's really rude how gross you think
your parents having sex is considering
it's how you happen you're like oh it I
guess I wonder if that's a a factor in
self-esteem like if people with really
high self-esteem are like you know the
idea of my parents making love is a
beautiful thing because it's just like
even your parents kissing it was like oh
oh it's horrible
I remember if my ma if my dad tried to
kiss my mom my mom would [__] kind of
threaten him with the cake cutter that's
good that's good
um she was a cake cutter why like was
there always cake like did you have
dessert growing up
no we'd had on birthdays we had cake
yeah and that's when they would have
some champagne together and my dad would
inch over and try to get a kiss on her
and she would raise that [__] cake
cutter the one that had the prongs it
was like oh yeah it had the handle and
then the like that and then a bunch of
straight prongs it looked like a comb
almost it was kind of like a server and
uh yes a cutter it was a multi-purpose
yeah thing oh wow that thing would take
yeah what is that that was for the cake
is that like a is that kind of like a
Cajun thing because we didn't have cake
Cutters like that
what's all the like the fingers going
down I think you could probably play a
song I mean who knew I don't know I
could have had a xylophone Tendencies I
don't know what some of the backstory of
it was yeah that harp what happened to
that harp that harp was everywhere no
the the doing doing oh yeah
what happened to that harp I don't know
yeah what was that thing what happened
to Snuff dude what happened to a cute
old lady in church taking a freaking hit
of that tobacco powder to the Dome you
know like the chewing tobacco thing I
did that did you do that I never did it
yeah I was a that was a big thing I
remember what snuff did you do I did the
Copenhagen I mean the powder you would
oh no but I've tried that God I tried
that so like that's just sniffing
tobacco yeah that's gotta make a
comeback
I would think that would right because
that's probably a pretty interesting
High
but I would think it's really nice for
you what if we got nicotine in our brain
cavity
because yeah Ricky ain't doing well
he's got uh he's got so snuff
oh see I thought that that was that's
the same container as chewing tobacco
right that's long cut now that's an
actual cut that you put into your lips
snuff is more there's dry snuff right
there if you click on that one one down
yeah one down right there yeah there's
dry snuff in that one if you zoom in on
that Zach
and you can see that uh
with that that's just a beautiful dust
right there
the snuff
it's interesting because that like so
Copenhagen Kodiak all that stuff right I
remember when they introduced uh the
pouches or maybe the pouches were all
always there and I never knew about them
yeah but you know those were all started
in Scandinavia because
it was cold outside and it was windy so
they had to how they consumed uh tobacco
was kind of chewing on it as opposed to
where you know they could light it right
easier if it was warmer out you know
what I mean man people will find a way
to get tobacco they need it huh right a
little nicotine buzz it just keeps you
going like it's all your ore it'll make
you go to the bathroom to make you stay
awake if you're driving it'll kind of
just get you through things you need to
do
I mean my parents smoked constantly yeah
constantly and I mean they all I mean
they died when they were 10 but like
they no but they they smoked constantly
and now no one really smokes oh
smoking's crazy like it's it's pretty
rare to see
someone smoke like someone
like I remember when they outlawed
smoking in bars in New York City I was
like well that's not gonna work and now
the craziest thing would be like seeing
uh someone Smoke on the subway you're
like not only are they breaking the
rules but like they're smoking like
that's just but now kids do the The
Vaping
actually worse for you right but it's
fun and it tastes good and you can have
all the flavors and it's like you can
have all the different flavors you want
um but kids lungs are getting decimated
because when you vape you're inhaling
oil as opposed to like cigarette you
were just inherent inhaling smoke so
but it's brutal because it's
it is so fun and it's portable right
it's portable you can do it inside you
can do it outside you see people in
Planes secretly taking a hit yeah you
know getting gassed up you see all types
of of people doing it um I worked on a
movie and this girl was
hammering yeah just constantly I mean
she was probably nervous
but like
um it makes you more nervous it does oh
it increases your anxiety if you have no
anxiety you hit that thing two hits all
of a sudden you're anxious you're scared
you're calling somebody you'll text the
cops hey what's up
you it creates anxiety do you do you
vape I have been a vapor I'll be honest
I have been a vapor I have Vaped and so
but like it's addictive right you can't
really get rid of it it's the most
addictive thing ever but you seem like
you kind of like were you always I mean
vaping hasn't always been around but
like when vaping came out you're like
this is my joint no I thought it was
kind of I thought it was something for
that gay men did honestly at first oh
really I thought it was but I was the
same way about the iPhone I was like
nobody's gonna you know that's so funny
this is I was the same thing about twins
when I saw twins for the first time I
was like this isn't
I remember in a sticker I remember when
email addresses like I had my email
address this is back when it was AOL and
it was my name and I remember a friend
of mine making fun of me like
you have your name and your email
address I mean this is going back and I
was like yeah so that way I can just
tell people and they're like okay like
what are you your own business it was
such and like I remember Greg Giraldo
making fun of me for having my website
Jim gaffigan.com he's like why do you
have a website and I was like well I
think everyone's is probably gonna have
a website and he's like no
according to him he overdosed no well of
course eventually he got a a website
that's what I mean but it was just like
it was one of those things it was and he
was a great guy and but it was and uh
but it was just it was just seen as a
little bit like unnecessary right like
you're being a bit much here yeah you
know like if you know like commercials
they used to like when they at the end
they'd be like you know visit
nabisco.com yeah by the way I'm getting
paid by Nabisco no I'm not but uh but
yeah it's crazy to think first of all
that anybody's ever gonna go to
nabisco.com right yeah it's like I'm
bored I'm gonna go to Nabisco see what
those Keebler elves are doing yeah yeah
I see some BTS of the elves dude right
yeah they're all on spring break right
it's a smooth sack summer
people want to Brand us up their balls
and get them nice that's what they want
and the leaders in below the waist
grooming are making sure we all have a
ball this summer by giving our pants
Partners everything they need to stay
fresh
dive head first in a smooth sack Summer
by going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with our code Theo
the manscape performance package 4.0 has
everything you need to de-hair that body
and get your body well get your ball bag
trimmed up get your ears you face God
trim your belly Boy Get Well homie
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer features a
Cutting Edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
advanced
skin safe technology
get 20 off and free shipping with code
Theo at manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code Theo at
manscape.com it's smooth Sac summer boys
get on board or get left behind
um what was yeah what was Greg geralda
like did you ever get to spend time with
him oh yeah I started I started with him
oh really I met him
at uh uh cold Waters
there was an open mic there that you had
to pay
and uh I think you had to pay like five
dollars and you'd go up and he and I
both showed up
I had uh and we were both wearing suits
we had a coat and tie on he was a lawyer
he was a real lawyer he was he went to
Harvard Law oh my gosh yeah he he went
to Columbia
on a scholarship and I think he went to
Harvard Law in a scholarship oh wow and
he was working for the best law firm and
or one of the great ones in New York
City
and um
and you know like yeah so we were it was
um
I can't remember but it was just because
this was probably
92 93.
and it was
you know add those open my like stand up
is much more middle class now but back
then it was it was a lot of people that
should just be in therapy yeah you know
it was a lot of people that I used to do
those open mics and then but poetry
opened mics there were poetry open mics
and you didn't have to pay for those and
those were just even more mentally ill
people oh yeah um just uh but I love
those people like there was the Bowery
Poetry Club
there was just these really uh surf
reality just these characters just these
uh your New York characters that were
and just you know like you weren't sure
if they were homeless or if they were
just kind of but there were the you know
there were some
a real uh real charactery people that
were oh yeah you'd have somebody with a
fern built into the side of their head
or you'd have like yeah yes somebody
who's somebody would just go up and they
would just pour blood on themselves yeah
you'd have someone with a pH balance of
like 11
000 go up there you know you would have
I mean I they would have I and then then
poetry was like it was almost like it
was too soft so it went the other way of
a Slam Poet yeah where you'd have
somebody just like throw a javelin throw
a white guy up there for you know two
minutes or so it was it was just and
then occasionally somebody would like re
so people would read their own because
there was slam poetry right are you not
hear my wings and they would just
[__] bee had a white guy here and
then they would just be like people
would read excerpts from their novel oh
yeah and people would be like
and they pass a gun around at the same
time that was the crazy part that was
the craziest thing dude it's like I
don't think we need this gun going
around what uh
so like the Russian Roulette would you
ever do that oh
I think on an a chamber I would I
wouldn't go on six though really
do they make an eight chamber uh
pistol
I'm sure they probably do like do you
own do you have a gun and a drawer in
your residence right now yes is it in a
safe or is it just kind of next to your
nightstand
it is accessible I would say without a
safe so if your girlfriend gets mouthy
you can take it out
I could set it out next to the
silverware okay I could certainly set it
next to the butter dish she just she
comes home and you're just waving it
where were you
and she's like I was just out with some
friends uh-huh
how crazy must the past have been uh
I I
followed you on your Apple device you
weren't with your friends yeah you were
at Dave and Buster's huh Dave and
Buster's and you know I got tokens yeah
who's Dave and Buster you're my quizzer
who are you [__] Dave or buster
you're out there with these mothers
these two men
who's Dave and Buster you know is there
food better than mine yeah tell me the
truth
um
would you do you think you'd ever murder
someone in a fit of rage
yeah you would right
what about you
oh yeah I think I probably could I mean
not that I haven't already no but I
would um
I don't know what would you do with the
body though that's the thing would you
tell on yourself or would you take a few
minutes to decide if you want to tell
yourself
I would I wouldn't tell on myself yeah
um that's interesting you know because
like people you know when someone
murders someone there's always kind of
like people are like and then they lied
about it afterwards yeah you know I mean
he killed his wife and then he concocted
this big but of course there what are
they supposed to do and be like I am a
man of Honor dear I mean it's like of
course they're gonna sit there and go
and try and get out of it you know what
I mean they're like oh you know what
I'll take 50 years in jail
I mean it's
uh but it is like the um yeah there's
there's killing someone and then there's
murder though right right I think
there's a way to kill somebody probably
humanely yeah a little more humanely
than murder there has to be some middle
ground in there like did you know of
anyone that got murdered in your town
um I have a I have a buddy who uh has
killed somebody yeah and was he caught
or did you just kind of out him he uh
was not caught he was not caught nope
and is it one of those things where he
you guys were having some beers and he
just started crying I I killed Angela or
or or did he tell you he's like I killed
Bob no we were yeah it was one time we
were doing drugs yeah you said it and I
just knew that he had done it wow
because I've had people all the time
were like I killed somebody and you're
like [__] you you know you haven't you
know wow and they're like you're right I
haven't dude and what was the reason for
them killing them
um I want to say it was like domestic
dispute really and it was gay men wow
wow
but I think there's a lot of domestic
disputes and I think the tough thing
about killing somebody right
is how do you say you kill somebody that
say if you asked 900 people yeah 99 and
they're like yeah you can kill Ernie
right you can kill Ernie so you do it
but how do you then how do you hide that
body how do you
yeah and where do you do it and then how
I would feel honestly like I owed
something to their family so I would
have to go and live next door to the
family and be helpful to them or
something for the rest of my life I feel
like without you know and I'd be like oh
damn I sure miss Ernie you know yeah and
say you know it'd be [__] up but I
would have to but they would eventually
forgive you and they'd be like oh you
know no but they didn't know you did
you'd make love to Ernie's wife
what if that happened
is Ernie married I think he is and I
think yeah at that point you get in you
assume the whole role of the family and
you just take over and maybe you rebuild
his life back to a level he could have
never built it to
and you changed her name to Ernie well
what about like getting rid of a body
like you ever notice that like you know
like I don't I Garden I like gardening I
know it's it's I don't want to brag but
I Garden yeah but I um like getting like
digging a hole
like you know some soil is easy to move
but some like you know if it's Clay
if you're trying to get rid of a body
and Clay you're an idiot you're
okay no but like you're like digging and
you're like you know what it's not gonna
be six then you're just like you're like
pile of leaves yeah like you can't go
deep enough it's just like if it's
really rocky soil you're like these
rocks I keep running into rocks yeah I
don't think this grave isn't going to be
a sedan it's going to be more of a
two-seater you know we're gonna go just
like this will be uh just a hatchback
it's great yeah and then the gracious a
foot and a half you're like all right
I'm just gonna chop off the head I'm
gonna bury the head here you have to
bury the other's head to the side and
then you go to the store and you're like
I'm gonna buy all those chemicals where
you kind of like Dexter melted bodies
and you're by the chemicals and you're
like you throw the body in there and it
doesn't work and you're like [__] and
then you look and you're like oh this
this chemical is not right so then you
gotta dump out the box
when you take the body and you throw it
in a dumpster and you're like and then
you're about to fall asleep and you're
like ah you know what that dumpster
they're gonna find that doctor because
you see a guy walking in the background
and kind of like what are you doing
you're like I'm not dumping a body right
that could happen oh it would be it
would be so hard except some people get
the hang of it and I think once you
unlock that code of how to get rid of a
body it's got to be right I mean yeah it
has to be like uh when you like Club 54
or whatever I mean you're just having a
blast then yeah it's just getting rid of
people so people get that's how they get
off though right yeah I think a lot of
people there's a lot of killers out
there and women like the shows I mean
that's one of the problems you've seen
with Society is during covid-19 all the
Dateline episodes got watched up right
yeah people watched every murder episode
these channels started repackaging the
same murders people like no no no I know
this is I've seen this murder you're
just trying to trip you know it's really
sad also then they started encouraging
people
they're like we need some content oh
they have to and and Netflix started
paying people to murder people would you
be surprised though no if they were like
uh there was like a list all right so I
gotta date her for two weeks
then I have to be angry wait a minute
I'm supposed to be on meth so it's like
all these variables to make a complex
interesting Dateline that you'd have to
you'd have to do all that but like it
would be worth it because yeah you'd get
paid great
well I think I could see I could totally
see if we get into a
Circle where networks which or some of
these big businesses are paying
especially networks are paying yeah I'll
pay a hundred thousand dollars for some
guy right you don't want a killing spree
a low-key through some other channel so
no it never faces back to me I get to
make a documentary about it that
documentary is going to make me five
hundred thousand dollars so why wouldn't
I just keep doing that right by the way
there is a uh a movie called man bites
dog which is great I think it's I don't
know what language it's in but before I
had kids and before I was married I used
to watch all these indie films and it's
amazing and it's about this documentary
Crew That's following
uh this serial killer and then they
start joining in like it's just how it's
kind of contagious yeah and how it's
it's you know like so like that they
they're like partying with the the
serial killer and then eventually they
get wasted and then it's really dark but
um it was kind of funny yeah anyway what
could see you I think you get kind of
accustomed to anything you know I'm a
rusty with a friend one time they were
playing volleyball every day in the
first day I was like I don't want to
play any volleyball I don't like it the
second day I got out there and the third
day I was the first person on the court
and then and before you know it you're
Gabrielle Reece yeah this is your
volleyball player I think yeah Gabby
Reese Gabby Reese yeah she married Laird
Hamilton didn't she really yeah I
thought we'll find we should find out I
thought she was married to uh yeah no
she's married to somebody else
is she married who's she married I think
it's layered Laird I think her husband
is layered
oh all right who's married to uh Richard
Marx I guess she's not a good marks
because Gabriel Reese she was on MTV too
right I don't know if she was Richard
Marx I don't know who Richard Marx he's
married to somebody she was a volleyball
player right Richard Marx is married to
who
is his wife Daisy Fuentes Daisy Fuentes
remember she was hot dude Richard Marx
is not that old no
I didn't know who he was but he he looks
like
um
Chris Isaac he wrote all the you don't
even know who he is do you see you're
too young the Marx Brothers I've heard
of no he wrote a bunch of songs and then
he wrote all these songs for
like the Backstreet Boys or something
like that
God that'd be nice you have another
skill man I mean you're I saw your movie
probably since we've last talked I saw
your movie I think I even sent you a
message about it
um
the one where you're the driver oh yeah
yeah
really cool oh thanks yeah that was fun
I love acting it's so fun
oh thanks well it's fun how much was it
how much did it cost to make that
they did that
I'm not they I know they did it for
maybe 250. wow and did a great job for
that oh thanks and
it was when we were shooting that
there's a car explosion
and we shot that in like I don't know 12
days wow and when the car explosion kind
of happened we had to shoot other things
and we kind of tried to get the car out
and and I remember us driving to the
other location the car was kind of still
on fire it was
fire truck I mean it wasn't believe me
it wasn't one of those things where we
uh
caused any damage to anything but it was
I mean it was this guy who was this
great director
um and uh Derek board and he uh but he
had he he lives in Virginia Beach and he
had a buddy who had a car dealership and
he's like can I have two of the same
cars because we needed two cars so
anyway but I remember there was a car
that was on fire and and we were and I
was like are we leaving that year and
they're like it's fine it's fine because
we had to shoot we had to get done with
this shoot
dude it's America's change you can leave
a burning car anywhere now I feel like
yeah well there's parts of uh
but I think it's it uh there's parts of
Virginia not Virginia Beach that's very
nice but like Norfolk and norfolk's nice
but there's Parts I was like whoa it's a
little yeah he's a little dangerous yeah
well there's some big cities they've
gotten even like like Minneapolis is
like deserted I feel like you know yeah
it's sad when I go there I'm like like
they drew all kind of murals like
there's more drawings of people in
Minneapolis than there are people
anymore it's I mean I love Minneapolis
too yeah you take your special there I
think we're taking the same time down
the street yeah and we couldn't we
couldn't see each other we couldn't see
each other because of the uh covid
coveted restrictions Netflix didn't
allow anyone in
to uh
uh the this I mean this was also this
and I have a new one now right that's
what yeah uh you have a new one coming
out it's your tenth one I know right
crazy that's unreal yeah I mean but it
is it's it's uh
it's you know it's all self-assignment
right and so what do you mean by that
when you say that well it's like you
know when you did your last special
you're like I'm gonna do this special
and you kind of set your mind to it and
you do it but like the the I think the
craziest thing is like when I did my
first special it was the expectation was
that
people would maybe do one or two or
maybe you know like Carlin did a bunch
but it was not
what it is now which is
where and it might it might change where
people every couple years put out a
special I don't think and that might
change but like you know I mean here we
are in this on a podcast I mean that
this didn't exist in its present form
five years ago yeah do you know what I
mean yeah where it's like people consume
like there's pressure for you to do
episodes because people
you know you know they they're kind of
like all right I need another hit right
yeah it's really kind of scary I think
sometimes you're like you've become a
dealer in a way you know yeah I mean you
become an Entertainer and you look
forward to having to chat with people
um
you also start to realize that people in
our business and and in different
businesses are so busy that sometimes
this is the realest chat you're going to
get with them yeah you know and I
started to realize that recently like I
went
um
where'd that go I went to do a podcast
and I was like man and my friend was
he's just a busy guy and I was like man
this is I wish I'd utilize that time a
little bit more with him just to really
be like oh this is our time to connect
it's just that's how you know if you
spend a couple hours with somebody
that's a lot of time so yeah it's
it is I'm jealous of I mean I don't
wanna I'm not gonna start my own podcast
but I am jealous of
because you know comedians you know you
get some success you never get to hang
out with people
you know I mean the more successful you
are the more you
and if you have other aspects of your
life you're not gonna get the quality
one-on-one time that you would normally
get and just for comedians this is kind
of our oxygen is yeah it's a good point
yeah I think it probably used to be
different you guys would hang out
together more was there more than I
think all of that happens too when
you're coming up as well yeah and I
think there was also just there was
you know there wasn't the touring and
doing theaters and which is great and I
love but it was
or you know if you were doing comedy
clubs there was you know three or four
people and you'd be there for multiple
nights and you knew
some of the wait staff and there was uh
you know you had more of uh
uh there was more of a communal
experience but it's all shifting
constantly and that's that's true too it
changes constantly and it's scary to
know if the next shift if you will apply
to it right that feels very scary a lot
of times if the next curve if you will
have
if whatever you're doing will have an
ability to kind of like uh
flourish in that space But I think that
you know I mean we talked a little bit
about this beforehand before we even saw
I think authenticity is what people
crave yeah and so
there are things that are shiny and
trendy and fancy but I think that if
it's authenticity
and it kind of kind of just to the times
it's kind of Timeless right yeah I think
you know yeah I think you want yeah yeah
I mean it's like there's always going to
be people
that have that come from uh similar
backgrounds to that we have yeah not
that I know anything about you but
you're a man yeah I mean it's like
there's you know but I don't know I
think that you know comedians we are
that's kind of a litmus test among our
peers is to to retain that authentic
that's not to say that there isn't some
fun and there isn't some pretending and
there isn't oh yeah you know
exaggeration but you know
it's also like I think when comedians
buy their own hype even when you know
even you know like when we were joking
around even like when comedians think
they are good looking that's kind of the
kiss of death right when they're like
well I am
I am a philosopher it's like well T you
know you have to be self-aware yeah it's
scary it's kind of scary because also
people are you start people start
telling you stuff and you have to be
careful not really to believe them you
have to just kind of know what your lane
is you have to stay out of your ego the
ego is really scary it is scary the ego
is really really scary especially I
think for guys who came from low
self-worth and then here's this false
sense of self-worth right or the or
here's this inflated it's like this
um it's like clothing it's like this
clothing it's like oh look at me look at
what you can do but the inside of you it
doesn't really uh it's it's not the
reality so yeah man that's been the
scare that's been something scary for me
is like be trying not to hear certain
things or just trying to keep my ego at
Bay I think it's ego but I think it's
also getting for me it's getting caught
up in other people's expectations which
is
it's not like a problem that you solve
once it's it's uh
uh you know like the fact that your
podcast is independent which is not good
or bad right or wrong or anything like
that is like the expectation
of of where what you're supposed to do
with things
is usually and it's changing but like I
guess what I'm saying is like the fact
that Rogan
you know everyone was like oh you're
supposed to do this you're supposed to
start your own podcast company
he kind of didn't get caught up in that
and then ended up doing that Spotify
deal and it's and and I think comedians
have a tendency to kind of go their own
path but for me when I sit there and I
go oh I should uh I should do this
that's what everyone else is doing
that's when I really mess up or it's
like oh that there's a that's a nice
dollar sign right you know my Asian said
that's good money and that's that's when
you get in trouble yeah is other
people's expectations rather than anyway
no no that's a great Point what do you
think what do you think is how do we how
do we
how do we kind of or what things come
into play there when we're trying to
figure that out because I'll have things
like that that come across and it's like
hey man you know this looks great this
is so many thousands of dollars I'm like
damn that looks great that yeah but then
it's like trying to know what trust
whatever your instinct is you know or
know what your instinct is that's really
hard sometimes right to know like is
this an instinct or is this a fear is
this like
an instinct telling me yes or is that my
ego telling me yes like right it starts
to get weird to [__] figure those
like who's like
who's at the front pointing at that
moment you know what part of you I think
it's it's like you know
it's you know I think the ego is very
impulsive right so it's like
maybe taking time and you know it sounds
corny the pros and the cons that helps a
lot you know I mean and also
you know you've got this successful
podcast but like also you have friends
and you can and you know
uh it's just kind of like you know like
your unique uh Sensibility
is is not something that someone could
tell you how to come up with you know I
mean it's like
that was on you but
I think I think input from uh and
but I think also tempered you know I
mean like it's like kind of take all the
advice and cut it in half like even when
people like badmouth someone I usually
typically cut it in half and
so that's why like if I really hate
someone I'm like I already cut it in
half of my age
I'm like all right
that's the bad [__] you did what um when
you and Geraldo were coming up did he
start off doing better than you you guys
were both doing well at the same time
was there competition there like what
kind of uh that's so crazy he was so
smart huh oh he was super smart and he
was also you know everyone liked him
yeah and he would help me get in to
because he grew up in Queens he would
help me get into clubs on Long Island I
was like this white bread guy you know
and like on Long Island they're like
who's this dork yeah man yeah and so uh
he but he would help me but yeah no he
had a lot of success and I was jealous
and I told him that I was jealous and uh
but you know it's weird because
you know it's not just about
the uh
the success I think it's like how we all
process
the failures like I almost feel like the
advantage I had was that
I had failed in a lot of things whereas
like people that were really successful
in everything they didn't have kind of
the appetite for it you know like or the
aptitude even for failure you have to
have some [__] yeah and you know like
some people that are allergic to
Cilantro they just it they're like it
tastes like soap it's like and so like
failure you have to have to have
uh uh you know
you know it's like be tempered by it a
little yeah you have to like you have to
have the calluses to deal with some of
it if that makes sense no I think it
makes a ton of sense man
um that's fascinating I wish I knew more
about him I always hear neat things
about him yeah
um his son's doing stand-ups really yeah
I don't know if I'm supposed to have
that but no good for him yeah that's
exciting man I always wonder what it
feels like uh I wonder if somebody's so
like imagine having a father that was
extremely famous right yeah like say
your father was
I'm trying to think of somebody who's
really really famous
um
who can we think of Pierce Brosnan or
yeah Carol O'Connor or
who else has a kid
well you know like um at the Quade oh
that Quaid family very interesting yeah
I want to interview the uh brother to
Randy yeah I mean well yeah you should
totally interview I want to interview
Randy Randy if you're out there would
love to uh sit down and chat with you
sometime man but their son jack yeah
because the sun's are extremely talented
and an amazing guy I got the interview
him years ago and he was Jackie do you
live in Nashville yeah and because I did
I did this show full circle with Dennis
and he lives in Nashville well Jesus oh
yeah Dennis lives there yeah but I'm
thinking Dennis brother Randy yeah but
like they might you know he might go to
visit his brother yeah
yeah Dennis lives over there I saw I was
picturing a magazine yeah yeah Randy
yeah that's a serious beer that's a
beard
that's uh you know that's when your face
is like hey I'm gonna live off the grid
that's that's kind of like you're not
going to tell me
what I should do with my beard at all
yeah because I'm not even going to be
able to hear you that's why because yeah
there's some CR there's some really
interesting videos of him and his wife
right I haven't seen is it like the uh
sex stuff no it's just he's because he's
uh yeah he's got out there he's got you
know um he's pretty strong right wing
views yeah is that a safe way to say it
I think so and he and his wife it was
really interesting because they were on
a park bench and they were uh getting
ready to drink I think some champagne or
something like that no on this video oh
in the video but they were I think it
was all about you know it was like about
Biden and stuff like that yeah I think
they'd get pretty political yeah
um but I would I mean Randy is an iconic
character you know his cousin Eddie
character was iconic yeah kind of that
wild how that kid I mean that's just and
then the sun's a huge star now yeah the
sun is maybe a bigger star than even
both of them were I mean they're all
they've all obviously have a lot of
talent in their family
um dude what about
[Music]
um
I love dessert don't you like it oh yeah
you know what I had yesterday bro
baklava dude really God man I didn't
even know what what was going on and I
had it and I was like wow they really
did it good you had it all right yeah no
it's great you know what I had yesterday
I was on a plane and they uh no it's
before the plane
I had have you ever had olive oil cake
it was amazing really it was amazing
but baklava what what where'd you have
it I had it from some Mediterraneans you
know yeah
a couple of uh
Mediterraneans brought it by
and God it was just so good right puts
on it bring up a chunk of baklava dude
let me even see it
because you know at the end of the night
I either want to [__] do something
horrible to myself or have some like a
sweet dessert yeah
it is yes so that's like God look at the
layers on that I mean that's almost like
something a geologist would cut out of
the earth well that's just how many
layers of and you know I think similar
to croissants it's like yeah each one of
those layers gets
uh uh a bunch of butter on it oh Greek
food is really underrated oh really
underrated good I love
um
yeah some of the pastries they look so
gentle
you don't even yeah you're like do we
eat this yeah it's it's baklava is it's
it's it's it's packed with sugar too
it's just yeah I think it's like it's
really dense I feel like there's
different
like there's different eras of sugar
like you know because like
rock candy they used to eat rock candy
mother loves it rock candy and then like
it was sugar on a little wooden Pole
right the chunk of Sugar by the way you
ever had straight sugar cane that's
great oh you just get it and I think
that's not bad for you wow because it's
not processed yeah that processing
really does a number and it does the
number on our bodies too yeah sugarcane
that stuff is so sweet it's unreal so
you know here's the thing that I thought
was so I did this movie Peter Pan where
I was uh I played a pirate so I kind of
went down a rabbit hole learning about
Pirates
and
so when sugar
became this big thing
that's where so like sugar people
started putting sugar in their tea and
their coffee and they put sugar in
everything people love sugar and it
destroyed people's teeth
and so like prior to that people's teeth
were fine but like once sugar happened
it devastated people's uh teeth here's
another interesting thing that I thought
was really wild is that like the coffee
break
was created
so that people would drink coffee
because when people drink coffee they're
more efficient at work so they wanted
people to drink coffee you know I don't
know if you drink coffee at all yeah I
like having but like it's like you can
kind of focus
and you can kind of I mean it also keeps
you regular but like you can focus so
like they wanted people to drink coffee
yeah I mean some people said there were
women that would get rid of if they if
they didn't have coffee they would get
rid of their children they couldn't
handle it you know they need it's part
of their day you know it's people it's a
staple in American dayhood and my
daughter who's 14 I think all my kids
love it but like
they love Starbucks they love Starbucks
like
how I loved McDonald's or Wendy's
they're all about the cake pop they're
all about that sugary you know those
shakes they're essentially just shakes
that they're getting but it's a social
atmosphere going to Starbucks yeah it's
a thing it's a it's a rite of passage
it's like now you're part of your day
you know yeah it's like the morning
paper almost yes it's fancy it's kind of
um adult pretending yes that's very true
I'm here to get my they have your name
written down yeah it's like yeah I'm
here for my coffee that I reserved kids
love it they love it and those cake pops
are just it's just a rip-off it's just a
DOT of a cookie oh it's nothing I can't
believe that that's anything bring that
up
that cake pop right and it's just
[__]
and It's gotta be as a bigger you know a
bigger guy sees you eating that he's
like what do you [__] what do you do
right you're doing huh who do you love
you know what's amazing is did you know
that there's cake pops they grow them on
trees
isn't that weird oh yeah there's
different trees there's like strawberry
cake trees in there and it's just the
way that they do it yeah they just grow
like that
dude they do add the sprinkles later
those aren't natural well you know what
will drive you did you know sugar most
of our sugar comes from beets what yeah
look up Nampa Nampa oh Idaho by the way
by the way beets be at Nampa dude beets
are very underrated vegetable and
they're making a comeback radishes are
making a comeback radishes are making
aren't they ready they are by the way I
grow radishes and my garden takes like
20 days easiest thing to grow so easy
easiest thing to grow and you can never
decide if they taste good or not but you
right it's because and you put I put
them in a salad and my kids are like ow
did you put jalapenos in here I'm like
those are radishes because my kids are
that white they're white they're white
out of yes dude that's hilarious what do
we have there we have Nampa sugar
let's look at them I'm going to be
honest with you here a lot of our sugar
in America comes from beets and that's
over in that's insane yeah I guess there
is a big company called Amalgamated
sugars that's based in Nampa and
the Nampa Factory process is 12 000 tons
of sugar beets sorry that's what they
are and granulates 1 000 tons of sugar
per day wow that's a lot in addition to
processing sugar beets into sugar and
molasses the Nampa Factor produces
animal feed products such as pulp and
betaine so women I'm kind of what does a
sugar beet mean I'm not sure is that
like a sugar stalk
sugar cane is that another thing there
you go
yeah sugarcane's different that's it oh
my God I never knew that let's look at
it I never knew wait a minute I know I
always thought I thought sugarcane was
where all sugar came from brother we all
do I thought it was I thought it was
you know from uh Cuba and Puerto Rico
yeah homie we got the sucker you know
what I mean yeah huh and that's why
there's Bacardi there and can we look at
Sugar Beets the Wiki of it or something
swimmer
and Nampa Viet Nampa as they call it
because I think there's a lot of issues
out there a sugar beet is a plant who's
not whose root contains a high
concentration of sucrose and which is
grown commercially for sugar production
yep oh my gosh sugar beets are grown in
climates that are too cold for sugar
cane oh that's interesting
in Russia 20 in 2020 Russia the United
States Germany France and Turkey were
the world's five largest sugar beet
producers
I mean if you ever occasionally just
hear about an animal that's never and
you I was working on this movie and this
woman was like because uh we have a
place and I thank you in in uh Upstate
New York and she's like oh yeah there's
a lot of uh blah blah like she was like
uh some type of cat and I was like
what's that and she's like you've never
heard of that it's like I like it was
just it's some kind of common wild you
know and you didn't know it existed I
didn't know it existed blows your mind
right yeah you're like how could I miss
out on someone it was she was like it's
the equivalent of like a mountain lion
I'm like what
I'm like yeah like what have I been
doing how could I not know that how
about the fact that bears used to be
everywhere
bears were everywhere
bears and wolves were everywhere oh I
would be imagine you're like hey I'm
gonna go
take a walk and people are like I don't
know if I would right yeah and you're
like [__] you I will and then you die
yeah well I think in China
people used to get eaten by tigers all
the time
yeah I think in in trying it in India
if you would just get eaten by a tiger
oh I would hate that and well imagine if
they start eating you you know you can't
get away what do you do then while it's
eating you like say it's got your leg
going down it right
and the pain is subside the pain your
your adrenaline will take over yeah so
you're just feeling you're just
horrified
you wouldn't even have like a weapon
you'd have a knife on you right and
you'd just be like if I'm going down
you're going down with me right what if
you don't have that
you just pet it you think
I think I'll try to put it to sleep if
it falls asleep you need to pet it and
just be like oh
like
maybe underneath the belly and they're
like oh
right
[Music]
hush little baby
remember nursery rhymes people would
always sing those to babies and now
people are like shut the [__] up kid
yeah
yeah nursery rhymes
hush a lot of them are really kind of
dark right
like a ring around the rosie that's
about like
the plague
and I think uh
um
was it ring around the Bros about the
plague I think it was
it's crazy
were your um
who took care of you when you were a kid
I was I live by myself no I um I was
um the youngest of six kids I mean I
kind of it was definitely you are the
there was nothing left in the parental
tank for you probably no not that's
interesting because some people usually
say oh you were spoiled but like there
was there was a burnout effect yeah
number four was spoiled dude you were
yeah and there was just uh you know
so like there were highly suspicious of
everything I had done
um
yeah but it was also there was I think
it was an ERA where kids were kind of
you know there would be like get out of
the house see it at eight you're a man
or see at dinner
but during the summer like we would
we would camp out like I can't imagine
my kids just camping out
but we used to do that we used to just
you know all right we're gonna build a
fire
and he'd just wake up at three in the
morning freezing yeah
you'd run home covered in bug bites
you're like why'd we do that
and then two weeks later you're like
should we do that again yeah right
you said you lived in up uh in Upstate
New York does Louis do you live by Louie
I don't know I know I don't think so I
think he lives up there somewhere yeah
I'm in like Westchester oh sweet I don't
know where that is but
so yeah so how many people how many
episodes of your podcast have you had
450 I think wow
452 452. and this is our last episode in
this studio actually is it now if I did
so I was on a in 2000 18 19
was it here no
it was at a different Studio that was
closer by uh towards the airport
and so how do you do you do you set up
did you design this or did someone else
no let me think a lot of like listeners
and stuff have sent things in that were
really cool they just put your Brody
Steve in somebody sent a lot of neat
things we have a deck a whole deck of
cards that somebody drew all these faces
on different cards from all of our
guests wow there's one of you in here
too somebody made but somebody made um
individual cards oh that's amazing this
is this is truly amazing somebody did
all those
um
so and then yeah I think uh
yeah we just kind of put it together I
don't know if we've always had the best
design aesthetic but what was the most
awkward
was there one where you're like this
feels like work or was there one where
an episode person's wasted oh Jesse
Ventura oh really the Baja yeah down in
the Baja now were you down there when
you did it or and I'll tell you why you
want to know why I'm not good at it but
and he um so he was the governor of
Minnesota yeah dude he's the governor
but he's he's now he's kind of
do you think he's got CTE oh I think
he's the mayor of dementia now oh
and was he was there hostility not a
chance
he's like I'm gonna leave in 30 minutes
let me tell you something for two and a
half hours
and he just talked the whole time I
thought yeah you know I shouldn't rip
him so much it was just it got to be
insufferable kind of and was was what
was your connection was he promoting a
book was he
was he uh he was in like a motorcycle
gang or something but I was just I think
I was just excited to talk to him you
know and just intrigued by him he had a
unique life you know to get to go to to
be a professional wrestler to be a
um he was an aqua marine I'm not sure
what it's called Uh seal yeah he was a
Navy SEAL but it was they do a lot of
the
they go in first and like we'll set like
a like check out the premises before
[Music]
uh maybe the Marines come and land I
can't remember what the group is called
but yeah a lot of underwater so it's
like underwater Uber Ubud did he play in
the NFL I feel like he played me you
know maybe Justin I don't remember if he
did but um yeah so that was just kind of
a tough one you know and then I think on
different days some of them are
different
some days I wish I knew more when I was
talking to people and some days I wish
that I was in like a better energy or
attitude you know
um has it been hard being a parent and
being like a famous person has that been
kind of tricky it is weird
um because you know
you don't really think of yourself as
you know having any level of Fame right
there's moments where you're like oh
this is sweet I get to
yeah get a restaurant uh I can go in a
restaurant and uh but
um
so there is moments where
um uh
I you know like my my my uh son at one
point when I was picking him up from
like soccer camp or something was like
yeah my uh the coach was kind of uh a
jerk saying oh yeah the funny guy you
know funny guy's kid you know I mean so
like that's weird but
um yeah I mean I don't know it's it's
strange because there is
uh you know the
you know it's weird because like my dad
was a small town Banker so I didn't
there's nothing to prepare you for it
you know I mean
so yeah totally and how could you know
how to prepare for it yeah and
especially it doesn't see it a lot of
times you don't feel like you're popular
you don't feel it's like you walk around
thinking oh I'm up it's like you're just
kind of living your life and then
there's this other realm that's kind of
going on that flares up every now and
then when you're in certain instances
yeah and or like if you're you know if
we're eating dinner with uh you know not
though we eat out really that often but
like if we're eating out and someone's
like comes up that's weird yeah do you
know what I mean and it's like I don't
mind it if I'm alone or if I'm after a
show and I'm in a restaurant but if I'm
with my family it's a little weird yeah
because you have to take a break from
that moment and then step out and then
it's like the center of attention is you
you have to act like I'm nice
in front of my kids and I don't like my
kids seeing me be kind
yeah I always wonder what the law like
what the effects of that are like what
are the residual effects that that you
don't even realize or that any popular
parent doesn't even realize you know
that a kid then how it affects their
life and then sometimes I was thinking
like imagine if your dad was like
extremely famous your dad was like
Napoleon Bonaparte or yeah um if your
dad was like uh Michael Jordan you know
how would you ever
make your dad feel like he means as much
to you as he does to like just some
stranger on you know I wonder if there
would always be some weird Hang-Ups you
know if you were that level of
popularity you have to be really
interesting yeah I think Napoleon's son
even became
I think he ruled France too oh really
yeah I think that like there was
I mean I think I don't know I want to
see that Napoleon Movie coming out
is there a new one yeah did you see Mel
Gibson's new movie yet which one's that
it's a documentary it's called the sound
of Freedom oh where that's a documentary
that's Jim Caviezel
right
um it's it's called the sound of Freedom
it's uh the incredible story of a former
government agent turned vigilante who
embarks On A Dangerous Mission to rescue
hundreds of children from sex
trafficking yeah that's Jim Caviezel
right
so yeah yeah I need to go see this is
that Mira Sorvino
oh
uh and Bill camp
oh wow yeah I think that's like the
number one movie
that's wild I gotta pee you do yeah I
always have to pee I had to pee before I
even came in here yeah go pee and we
will do another 20 minutes
what do you quit smoking no I'm addicted
to this you're addicted to nicotine dog
yeah oh my God bro yeah why not yeah
you're right oh if they had cocaine the
gum
laughs
I'm sure they probably have some I'm
surprised that's not like at some store
oh yeah cocaine gum it's good because
you know you'd have a buddy it's not
addictive because your children yeah
yeah it's not addictive if you cheer for
the Mets no it's good it's good for your
jawline too
you get the Coke and gum that's fine
yeah it's cheaper than regular cocaine
too oh yeah my cousin he had half of his
uh growth
yeah that was the thing in the old west
was cocaine gum
wow [__] yeah dude now that's I would go
through it yeah I'd ride off into the
heat dude if I was on cocaine gum look
how they used to spell it too with no e
on that little jar
cocaine but you know did you used to
party with it some ever with cocaine
yeah I've done it but you know yeah me
too you know
you were like yeah me too oh dude it's
right oh you know what I think about it
sometimes I think about us meeting up in
like a room like and you know like
having a eloping I literally think about
that like me riding off in a carriage in
the night with the eight ball just
holding on to me from behind you know
the um
that's that's one of the influences of
having kids is like
it kind of removes some of the stupidity
stuff from you like you're like wow I
can't do that yeah you can't do it
anymore well it's like a baby is born
and you you look at the baby and your
first thought as well and it takes
suicide off the table
you know I mean it's it's a really dark
thing but it kind of is true and you're
like and now you're like man I can't do
that yeah yeah but here goes gymnastics
yeah
you're like all right I guess I can't be
a hobo anymore do you know what I mean
so there is things like that in your
life that start to disappear like
there's there's like years where you're
watching football and you're like yeah
one day I'll get back out there and play
even if you never played you're like one
of these days I'll be back out there you
know yeah they'll miss me somebody will
call them need a free agent yeah yeah or
they'll do a strike and they'll try it
they'll need a Long Snapper
is there anyone here in the stadium I
could do long snapping I did that in
high school
and then even those ideas start to they
don't show up anymore then there's just
not a chance well there is like the the
Olympic dreams die yeah you're like all
right well that's like also when
quarterbacks are retiring and they're
like 20 years younger than you you're
like
so Tom Brady's that old he's only 45.
you're like oh I guess
I guess I am old yeah
um
yeah you've done a a lot of acting with
this with this many specials do you
think about slowing it down what do you
think do you start to have has your view
or your Vantage Point got different
um I don't know if anybody has as many
specials as you I mean you might be the
most prolific
well it is uh
it is weird I think it's like well with
I think we're all kind of reevaluating
what we're doing all the time but
some of it I think was motivating
motivated by when I tour I definitely
want the audience to
see a new show
and then
there is such a sense of
completion in finishing the hour
and then I don't know I feel like with
stand up I'm kind of
I'm getting better you know like there's
all right uh you know I'll be like all
right I'm gonna
I want to tell some stories all right
now I want to talk about uh I don't want
to talk about food at all which was like
another uh hurdle of mine and then I was
like all right I'm gonna talk my wife
had a brain tumor I'm going to talk
about the brain tumor and then
um all right I you know like I could
just talk about my kids constantly but
I'm like I'm not gonna just because I
was like that 26 year old guy sitting in
a comedy club hearing people talk about
their kids yeah I can't even get a date
so um you know I mean so there's the
assignment of it but
yeah I don't know there is something of
uh um
because in the weird the weird way we're
doing it for ourselves right and so
when you get off stage and people are
like thank you so much you're like I was
just doing that for myself you know it
was like I had fun you know it's like
you know there was this there used to be
this saying like doing colleges you're
not paid for the show you're paid
because it's so hard to get to them yeah
I mean although that's always the worst
yeah and so But to answer your question
I do feel like
I don't know yeah I mean
definitely you know
taking some time but it is I enjoy it's
the creative fulfillment that's yeah
that's that's huge well that's a that's
and I think I think that people that
have podcasts get that'll that buzz
uh and you know it's and and I enjoy
acting and I get it there but like
acting so
um it's so erratic on when you can do it
so
um
yeah there's there's definitely like uh
I think a fulfillment aspect for people
like you get to the end of a of a
chapter in your life you don't want it
you just you challenge yourself I don't
want to talk about this anymore I want
to try something new you also feel
yourself evolving you know that's
something I feel in my own life
sometimes now for like some of the first
time in probably forever I've started to
feel like oh man I'm evolving a little
bit I need to I want to start
thinking in different patterns and
talking about stuff that maybe has more
is like more thoughtful to me but then
sometimes it's like you don't want to
get too crazy and you want to make sure
that people are just having fun you know
absolutely it's like you don't want to
turn into some like you know guy who's
just like preaching you know so that can
be kind of a tough that can be tough a
little bit sometimes to manage and I
think comedians we I I think people are
always so surprised at how sincere
comedians are that's not to say that
we're we don't joke around and have fun
but like but we have to keep a balance
on that sincerity because if we get too
sincere then we're just then we might as
well just be a preacher yeah yeah I mean
then we're like you know the way we
should do go you know it's like we might
as well just be preaching you know did
you see that little kid that Pentecostal
kid recently they had a kid who was
doing
speaking in tongues he was a young
preacher now did you growing up did you
go to church we would sometimes my dad
would take us over there I mean my dad
was so old when I was young when I was a
child and so he would walk over there to
church and he'd fall asleep he'd fall
asleep wherever we were yeah and so when
I got there I was kind of on my own
wherever we went you know my dad was
like I'll introduce you to people we go
we'd sit down for a second till we could
take a break and then he'd be [__]
dead asleep so then I would just be kind
of like in these places and I had this
sleeping father that felt uncomfortable
and then I was there and had to kind of
like navigate some situations that kind
of stuff would happen a lot with my dad
and how what kind of church was it was
it Presbyterian Presbyterian yeah they
had three nice oak trees I remember
and uh they tried to do an insurance
fire once or twice but it didn't take
and
and um
great breakfast over there though
right God nothing will bring you home
you know nothing will bring you to the
Lord like a dang one of those donuts
with pink frosting and uh think of like
different churches like you remember
like we went to this church uh in
Maryland that
uh just amazing you go and get pizza oh
donuts and you know you're like yeah you
just leave a little hungover on Sunday
and you're like this is sweet you don't
have a little kick from that lemonade
you're like this is perfect yeah God
knows what I need but
yeah church was fun I thought the
funnest thing about church was just kids
playing and stuff like like a social
environment yeah you know and it used to
be that was the place you saw anybody
they didn't have all this other stuff
you had to you know fight off yellow
fever all week and dysentery and get
everybody's butts clean and everything
and then wagging them up to church and
that's where you'd see somebody and hope
somebody would with a little bit of
money would make love to your daughter
or you know or you know that's where you
know that's where it happened it all
happened right there on the you know and
you know it's like you know there is
something strange about because also I
spent
my 20s and you know my 30s very much
opposed to it and then I married this
woman that that is Catholic and I mean I
was raised Catholic but kind of just
kind of culturally and but there is
something about there's a quietness
there
that you know there's something
meditative about it and maybe because
it's so boring but it was it's there is
something about like all right I'm just
standing there with my kids I'm just
sitting there with my kids it's
it's like the world slows down like I
you know you see why people go and why
they have a connection to it yeah I love
I mean I love Faith you know I have I
feel like I have a good faith you know I
like being able to close my eyes and and
I like to pray twice a day I like to be
able to think about God and and and talk
and or my God and ask him you know what
I can do for others and just things like
that or if I need help to offer me some
suggestion
um I love that kind of stuff and one of
the best times I've ever had in my life
or best I ever felt was when I felt like
I had a really strong connection to a
higher power yeah and I'd worked on it a
lot and it really came to fruition and
even if some people say well that's
Voodoo whatever it is doesn't matter it
worked it like I it worked as much as it
as it it was real as far as I knew and
if that's a if that's the truth to me
then that's great well it's also you
talk about you you had mentioned before
ego right like that humility
or just a concept of humility is so
necessary right to navigate this because
if you let the ego take over
it's trouble you know what I mean and I
know yeah I know that to some people
listening that we just sound like we're
saying gobbledygook but like it is one
of those like when you you know you're
somebody that if you you know like I've
struggled with my ego and stuff like
that it's like the only way you can get
that in line is having some humility and
like and the premise of religion that or
belief system that there's a higher
power
is is very kind of
it's like that's structurally
you know literally
puts you in a position of of humbleness
yeah I mean because you're working with
alongside somebody else or for somebody
else yeah yeah oh I'm so grateful that
there's something else out there that I
can believe because
yeah I think I like rejected the world
so much that I was in growing up that I
wasn't gonna take Direction
from anybody in it probably you know I
hated my environment so much I despised
like I mean I despised my [__]
environment you know it just I mean it
everything about it [__] hurt me I
felt like right that's how I felt anyway
yeah and so
the no one in the war of human probably
would I ever
really believe in right so you almost
need this other this this uh satellite
to beam through this other entity to
help me get adjusted to trust
the world again and so that's why I'm
man because for me and everybody can
have their own thoughts I don't but for
me as long as they're the same as mine
I'm fighting with it but for me man I'm
so because I wouldn't believe you just
said Hey listen to this guy I don't know
if I would have done that but you give
me a a hype an invisible being right
yeah visually invisible
you know
and it's just and there's just enough
malleability in there for me to say okay
I'm well I'm willing to try this and
then it opens up more of a door for me
of like um of connection does that make
any sense yes I think also like even
saying I I I I think you know the whole
agnostic I don't know is
that's that's just where you got to be
you know I mean it's like it's like I
don't you know I think that human beings
are so arrogant and the assumption that
like every generation has thought that
they've had it figured out and every
generation has been wrong yeah you know
I mean like
even you know so it's like
if we can't be like we don't know okay
then we're really kind of starting from
a bad position
so yeah dude I don't know how do you
think you'd have been like a good like
if you go back to those times you go on
a date like would you have been like a
good settler you think where would you
have best done in history where would
you have best been yeah gosh
I sometimes think about like my
immigrant ancestors because you know
my I did that Finding Your Roots show I
haven't seen it so uh that's where they
they kind of they do your own you did
that yeah where they take you to the
library well no mine was uh uh where
they kind of like tracked my mother's
side and my father's side
and they get to go meet someone at a
mall or anything no no I didn't this was
uh
but like so my grandfather
made dentures and I remember thinking oh
he made Dentures that's interesting you
know like yeah Dental stuff and
but what I learned through that show is
that my grandfather broke this cycle of
working in the coal mine
that had existed for Generations
and so I think of like my ancestors that
came over from Ireland you know and just
like
that was that was rough
and you know like there's an ancestor
that was framed for murder oh and how
would you even prove you didn't do it
back then like you did it well by the
way I think because he was uh they uh
you know it was kind of theorized that
he was a
um kind of like there was this
anti-immigrant stuff going on and being
an Irish or immigrant that he was part
of the Molly Maguires and so they framed
him and then they kind of he got
pardoned by the governor and they don't
know you know like they never explained
why he was pardoned you know was he
pardoned because he was innocent was he
pardoned because he was crooked because
he was crooked you know and so wow but
like yeah so like a different era I feel
like I'm so pale that
you know like I need sunscreen you know
even by a computer huh yeah open in the
fridge oh so I uh yeah that's got to be
the saddest dude if you're real pale
because then if you open the fridge
everybody sees you too yeah it's like
bigger and pale and so no but like I
mean it's not sad it's beautiful but
it's like
what era would you be in
um
I don't know the future seems way sketch
you know it's just I feel like gonna be
people like you drive up to a machine
that feeds you and then you come into it
yeah it would but it has to be in the
past
Civil War could have been interesting
right and if you would have been like a
referee I think yeah I mean Civil War
but like people were just so many people
were killed like the the equipment
uh like the the weapons were so yeah
it's like they and it's like you got
shot they just chop off your leg you
know what I mean yeah they didn't even
have to be shot in the legs
yeah a lot of their technical skills
were way limited it seems yeah dude
whereas I think like like if some people
even if they had just had like down
syndrome they're like oh he got shot by
something like no this guy he's fine
he's fine he's just over here raking
leaves let this guy live Milan
um I think there was a lot of stuff like
that yeah like but I don't know maybe
but then I don't know you're right
people smelled so bad I don't know if I
would want to be a pilgrim because
you're like well we're almost there and
everybody's dying and then you get there
you have nothing to do there's nobody
even waiting when you get there I do
think that the south is really
fascinating I know you're you know
Louisiana oh yeah it is it's because
there's a civility there
that you know y'all and yes ma'am uh yes
sir it's
that is
so different from the Midwest where I'm
from but
it's it there's a civility there and an
authentic kindness that
is kind of unique you know it's kind of
this
remnants of the British thing with like
the sweet tea versus the British
drinking tea yeah there's kind of an old
traditionalism there yeah that really
comes I mean there's also tons of racism
oh yeah I mean if you get it it's a real
it's a little slave you get into
Mississippi it's a little slavy you know
but that kindness is fascinating yeah
right yeah that's the crazy part about
the south it had this like it also it
had like two whole different ends of the
spectrum you know
it was like be a gentleman be polite but
if you're black you're not allowed to
comment yeah yeah
so they had I mean that was just unreal
I can't even imagine that people went
through all those times it's really
crazy to think that as humans where we
sit today it's it's like it's pretty
unreal and how quickly we [__] got to
the place where we're just sitting here
you know
um masturbating into a phone right well
also like the so we look at the bigotry
or the bias of the past
what biases exist today
that are the equivalent to you know
women couldn't vote until 1920. you know
uh really African-Americans couldn't
freely vote until the 60s
and so like it's like what what kind of
it's not like we're done you know I mean
like there's some biases that exist
today that we are kind of unaware of
we're like what's wrong with that you
know what I mean like there's nothing
wrong like even like people like I think
when I started stand up people used to
do [__] jokes and they used to always
drive me crazy yeah and um
and people don't really do that anymore
but like I'm sure I do jokes where
people are like in 40 years people are
gonna be like that hateful gym gas yeah
look at this hate Monger look at this he
was like he would talk about beef Jim
Crow Jeff again he would talk about meat
yeah like they ate meat back then like
we're gonna realize like the you know
like we're become we'll be all become
Hindu and like you know the cows sacred
bee excuse can we all become him you
then your material is hate speech it's
hate speech bacon bacon who are you just
like what's going on
yeah you know like to Muslims and Jewish
people it's like I'm glorifying this
sinful thing
you know it's so weird do that so true
depending on upon how the future looks
at things yeah or how they even choose
to look at things as like writers of
Articles and this and that you could be
vilified well I mean I think even the
Roseanne thing that happened on your
podcast yeah is
I mean maybe I'm just kind of opening my
eyes a little bit to it but like it
literally took me two seconds so I saw
she was trending so what she said then I
watched the clip and I was like
obviously she was joking
she was being sarcastic Why didn't
and I don't even know that's all I know
like I didn't talk to anyone else about
it does it still exist as an issue no no
it was going away it was just yeah it
was just crazy they just like they took
our episode down and they said that we
they gave us like a strike on our
Channel because they have like
like but they retracted it right they
didn't but they have their policies and
we couldn't post for like a week so
those you know that's YouTube and their
policies they deemed it like hate speech
and that's their
that's their rules right and so that's
you know I'm grateful to YouTube because
I get to have this this platform at the
same time I I don't uh you know I
disagree with them
but I think that anyone that
oh and and you know that's where it's
like you know any individual who works
at YouTube would probably as an
individual see that what you know
Roseanne the legendary comedian and what
she was saying was and I think she's
Jewish would not
view that as what
some anti-semitic person would say yeah
do you know what I mean oh yeah yeah
totally I mean it was it definitely was
interesting though I got him some if
some Rabbi emailed me and invited me to
some summer camp or something and uh but
it was like eleven hundred dollars I'm
not going on that and then of course the
Holocaust happened like who would ever
you know oh my gosh every third book at
the airport is about it how you know
what I'm saying of course it happened
well I think it's also uh you know not
to excuse the overreaction but I
actually do think that
there is
um
uh uh an almost normalizing of
anti-Semitic speech and I also think
that and I'm not saying because it's
different when it's Roseanne Barr and uh
and like someone who is just a flat out
anti-semite or like speaking in
anti-semitic tropes it's like I do think
it's you know there's no comparing what
uh Roseanne said to us but these other
people would do right if there's like a
real hateful person yeah I mean and by
the way I think anti-Semitism is like
I mean look you know most commit like
I'll have I don't know what percentage
of comedians are Jewish but it's like
all our friends are Jewish and it's like
you can't you know you know you you you
you know stand-up comedy is a Jewish
American art form that like is you know
so many of the Great comedians were
Jewish so oh yeah you have you end up
being educated on anti-Semitism and you
can't do a spot at the cellar without
hearing three comedians do jokes about
the Jewish American experience and
anti-Semitism yeah I mean it's like
yeah I think it's
yeah I wish I had a like I can't tell if
people bringing light to that
creates
makes things
better or worse in that space right you
know because no one said anything about
it like you know a million people had
watched the video there wasn't even a
comment about it on YouTube right and
then somebody makes a clip
and purposely like is like hey look at
this right and this is yeah the view of
it I you know you don't want to create
like a boy who cried wolf situation
either and so that's you know especially
when it's something as important as like
um as people being hateful you know it's
like you don't yeah that's so some of
that is where some of my fear comes in
like let's yeah we don't want people to
become numb to it right
right so but then also you know
everybody has their their their
different thoughts on it and and I
respect different people's thoughts on
it you know I respect that people come
from different places and and I respect
different people's thoughts on it um
but yeah um
dude I have a problem with how we
with that we keep putting Joe Biden out
there I feel like as a nation it makes
us look like oh this is how and that we
pretend everything is okay like doesn't
that seem weird to you yeah well I mean
I I'm somebody like I think that
if Trump wasn't there or maybe I'm just
imagining this I think if Trump wasn't
there Biden would be like I'm done
thanks everyone you know I mean I wanted
to be good night dear I mean like I
think that might put on some long johns
in this show he'd be like I'm exhausted
I'm exhausted I want to go and hang out
uh with my wife yeah yeah you know what
I mean and uh
and hang out with Barack I don't want to
do this anymore but like someone eat ice
cream with the former press I want
baracki Road dude he's got to come out
but like yeah I think you know there's a
difference between like the people that
don't want to
that again I think ego gets in the way
of like the greater good right yeah and
I don't but I don't know maybe he is
like uh you know I'm great but I think
it's fast I'm trying to write this thing
all about how
I mean I saw Harrison Ford in
um that Raiders of the Lost Ark number
four or whatever yeah he's 80. it was
great it was an action movie
and it's like
you know 80 for Brady it's like they're
all 80. yeah
it's a good point and so yeah you want
people to have long career yeah I'm look
but I just feel like if we embr like if
maybe the media was like this is our guy
he's gonna say some [__] you know
instead of I feel like we put this like
people try to pretend that it's that
he's not getting unwell that's the part
to me that it doesn't look weird to
other people if it's like this is how we
treat our senior citizens you know like
as America like how we treat I mean I
think it's like I thought your point
would be more like everything's fine
like we're living in a state of denial
but I also felt that like
during the entire pandemic when Trump
would do his daily
newscast that we were all like yeah
it'll be fine it'll be fine it's like
this guy is it's
dear I mean it's and we've all had Bad
Bosses yeah do you know what I mean it's
like
but I also feel I don't know it's weird
I I you know I really do think that if
if there was if if if if Trump was not a
possibility I think Biden be like see
you later he'd be like I did my thing
I'm gonna be in the history books
goodbye everyone
Michigan J frog yeah it's uh that's a
good point I hadn't thought about that
maybe it's just more of like a defense
um
but yeah policy has just gotten so
strange it used to be so different
didn't it felt like we were all behind a
leader didn't it feel like that I feel
like it I mean I used to
it was so strange because I grew up in
this small town
Indiana is a very red State and uh I
lived in Manhattan I live in Manhattan
and that's very blue and and the
entertainment industry it's very liberal
and comedians are very contrarian and so
I loved I relish having friends of
different opinions like at the Fourth of
July I had a friend there who's a big
kind of conservative like
um you know he's you know he's all in on
DeSantis and then I had a friend there
that was you know that wouldn't vote for
you know vote for Hillary you know I
mean uh so left like Occupy Wall Street
left and so it's like I like that
diversity of opinion
but and I and I feel like people that
come to my shows
um like even in uh the dark pale thing I
have this this material on global
warming and you know when I performed it
around the country there'd be some
people that are like
all right
global warming maybe you're I mean
whereas like they're going they're
giving me the they're like all right I
don't know if I buy the premise right
but I'm gonna have to I'll listen to the
jokes yeah and so
uh I liked that uh they're open to that
but
um there is also
I don't know it's weird I know I'm kind
of rambling no it's okay and we can even
take that part out if we felt like it
was too rambly if we for both of us kind
of you know
um let's take a little bit of news and
then we'll get you out of here Jim sure
because your special is coming out in a
few days and the name of it is dark pale
dark pale oh yes dark pal
that would be your native it would be
your Indian name huh Dirk pale dark pale
dark pale
uh yeah so it's uh you know it's kind of
I wanted to go a little bit you know I
think comedians uh you know our on-stage
personas are a little bit more
accessible
and that maybe you know like what makes
comedians laugh when we hang out is
usually darker oh yeah than what's on
stage and so it's kind of opening some
of that up and also talking and I think
that over the past five years we've gone
through so much Darkness you know we've
all lost someone
lost some people you know what I mean
and um so there's a little dose of
nihilism that I think we need I think we
need right yeah yeah I mean some people
think we need a war really yeah
oh that's so interesting where'd you
hear that everywhere
we need a war because they think it
would put people back on the same side
we had a common enemy
that's interesting because there is part
of like what's going to get us together
and all right as soon as somebody says
hey it's us against them it's like all
right let's do this you know
yeah I think that
I I don't know I think it's interesting
I think I think coming from this split
background of
you know uh I you know I have real
resentment when people talk about the
middle of the country or flyover states
yeah me too it's like I think that
that has to be shamed for the stupidity
that it is
because
um you know again we were talking about
the it's not like you're not gonna get a
great meal you know I mean like there's
this there's this
um
this dismissive stereotype and you'd
think it would shrink with the internet
but I feel like it's almost kind of
grown
where people are just I always think
it's so weird when I do
I'll do like a podcast or I'll be
interviewed and someone will be like so
is it different doing material in
different parts of the country I'm like
not really
dear I mean it's like it's not really
that different uh-uh do I mean it's not
like people don't have every piece of
technology or every form of
entertainment yeah everywhere culturally
we're very
uh it's and by the way the world is like
that it's like if anything culture is
disappearing so
they're not that's not to say that there
aren't different viewpoints on things uh
I don't mean to contradict myself
earlier but like it's not like there's
a real huge difference
on right like from here to there yeah
right you know but I guess I mean
there's some like I know whenever I've
been in like Illinois and certain places
out there rural areas they don't even
have 5G on their phone so it's like if
they want it's like more of a they have
to be at home and be on their Wi-Fi
to really be Milling on their phones as
much you know oh really um like some of
my friends that work in like farming
communities and stuff like that so I
think in some areas there's probably a
little bit less consumption oh yeah no
where we uh we have a place that we got
uh after the pandemic and
if I'm outside working in my garden I
have no service whatsoever yeah like
there's just it's just a no man land
for uh cell service so like my wife
literally has to open the door like it's
1943. damn
get in here your kids are doing this and
I'll waddle over yeah with my basket of
my Harvest yeah I love my garden you do
Garden at all I don't Garden man I would
like to have it someday I will once I
quit touring a little bit after next
year what do you like to grow in your
garden I I love to grow just about
everything but like I'm jealous of like
so Louisiana I could probably grow
peanuts down there oh yeah I could you
know I uh I don't have that long of a
season so like there's some things that
I can't grow that
and some of it is it is so interesting
to grow things can you grow wheat I
could grow wheat I grow corn
I grow cucumbers I grow uh pumpkins
Peppers but like even Peppers it's like
it's you know um you know North it's not
that nobody wants a northern pepper no
well it's a ballito when it walks in but
like it's you know you don't it takes
it's you gotta wait you need some
real hot weather we need some harshness
you need some [__] pain in the oven
yeah [__] soil for Peppa black all
right [__] yeah I got this [__]
right you know that's the kind of pepper
you want dog yeah I just got out yeah
you want some you know the peppers are
the best God they're so good huh right
whoever had them first was such a
[__] weirdo but they were they are
good oh they're amazing what do I love
putting in my mouth I'm trying to think
oh dude when I had those you know a lot
of Asian people will fry up a
um
little cut of yam have you ever had that
no my God is it good
yeah so women Louisiana you like okra
yeah I didn't mind it but then people
start frying it and it tastes dude it
starts to look like it's been giving a
[__] to somebody it gets real uh
viscous yeah yeah no it's I like it in a
gumbo but otherwise I'm like
I'm like I don't know about it okay yeah
when you lift up a spoonful of it it has
like a trail that goes back to the stuff
and you're like whoa this thing has been
yeah doing BJs you know yeah it's a bit
slimy yeah it's real slimy yeah so I
don't mind but what else do I like man I
like broccoli plain
you know my taste buds change over the
years I'd have started liking tiramisu
to be honest with you oh really yeah you
are a dessert guy God I [__] want it
boy when it's nighttime [__]
yeah I will get up in the middle of the
night it's more than chocolate well it
keeps me off of vaping I notice if I can
get a sugar in me I'll wake up the
middle of the night and put some peanut
butter on my tongue and go back to sleep
better that's I want to grow peanuts I
think peanuts but if you could do it Jim
Gaffigan's peanut butter oh my God I
would love to do it but peanuts
I I haven't even watched a video of this
but I think the peanut plant grows and
then the flowers drop into the ground
and they become the peanuts oh it's
beautiful
it's so crazy I'm growing potatoes oh
yeah I could see that I'm very excited
about that and carrots are fun to grow
yeah carrots are fun to grow you're
gonna cut all this out of the podcast
because it's so boring bro it's the best
part I think
um um what else would I like to have
onions garlic I love garlic garlic is
probably one of the best
garlic is good it just feels so
um
it looks like something's wrong with it
oh it looks alien yeah it looks a little
alien
um I do like seeing uh I like
watermelons oh watermelons are fun that
would be great to grow in the South yeah
because watermelons and pumpkins
you just and squash you turn you turn
your back you look back it's like
they've grown a foot yeah it's crazy how
big is your garden square feet are we
talking it's not that big I have two I I
built one
that when we got the place it was kind
of already there
and then
um
and then here let me see what I got here
this is oh there's a picture of you
right there in some Garden that looks
like no this is a hike but this is my
garden right now that's those are the
raised beds oh yeah see that's oh wow
Jim this is beautiful yeah
but I have this it's my wife calls it
the English garden and then that's oh
that's that's my Irish garden and so the
Irish Garden was there was kind of this
field
that
um I kind of converted now this is what
see that field up there this is what
that field looks like now
so it's
oh that's great man these are both on
the same property yeah
and so one does look more Irish yeah
right this one looks more like it could
have a headstone in part of it yeah and
so uh but this is you know how like you
waste time I don't know if you waste
time on Instagram so like on scrolling
and all that oh yeah on Tick Tock I
scroll on Instagram on stories but I'm
just watching people harvesting stuff
that's beautiful now there's something
romantic about that I think yeah you
know get out there in the dirt
oh yeah my grandmother used to make us
put these nets over her strawberries so
the crows didn't get them oh yeah you
know she lived out in Illinois and Rural
Illinois and they had a rain barrel out
there and they would collect rain yeah
and um did she have any paint did she
ever paint rocks to look like
strawberries to tricks yeah to trick the
crows yeah dude I never realized that's
why she did that but she would always
have these painted rocks yeah so the
birds would come down they'd Peck at the
Rock and then they'd be like forget it
and they'd leave
ah Athens that both the bird and the
human that do that are freaking wild
um and that's that'd be crazy like this
would be like what if you put a stone
woman outside you know and some rapist
runs up the Scarecrow right the
Scarecrow is supposed to scare it's
pretty crazy how
there's uh all these things to trick the
animals to trick the animals and also
and then there's companion planting
which is fun but I just and what is that
plants need friends kind of you know
plants need friends or will some people
talk to their plants yeah I've seen that
before and uh but a companion plant is
like
planting something uh nearby that either
will help
um with nutrients or will deter
pests so for instance
onions
or uh certain pests don't like the smell
of it
and then
um you know oh yeah bro like uh uh
cilantro is it will deter things and
um you know basil oh yeah I like having
some basil huh basil is amazing a lot of
women who are having a tough time grow
basil I feel like
well it's you know it'll bolt it's like
you gotta you got a secession plant none
of this is going to end up in the
episode oh I think it's interesting um
let's get into a couple new things and
we'll get you out of here Jim what
happened in the news anything exact
what happened there's a video going
around I guess a mayor in Mexico married
an alligator
um that's I guess that's a good luck
thing
but this is real
no this isn't part of some ritual yeah
no oh yeah oh it is part of a ritual uh
these are locked to the town
yeah not surprised it seems kind of we
also have his mouth shut like that
what else we got
did they consummate the marriage
right there used to be a YouTube video
of a man making love to a
uh big Chow like a chow animal in a park
on YouTube for years that they couldn't
get down for some reason
yeah and I think it was in Santa Monica
oh is this about sharks everywhere no no
this video has gotten a ton of views I
guess this woman was uh faking cleaning
up a beach for social media and then
left all the trash there after this has
five million views and a lot of people
have a problem with this oh
oh wow yeah it's all just for show now
so this girl's Faking It
oh and then she just left the bag there
um not shocked
that's what happens man if people they
it's just about what the look is you
know
it's hard
what is that that is a simple it's a
sickness huh
it's
well it's the absence of
right or wrong I remember one time I saw
a movie recently
and um
I was with my 10 year old
and we were with a friend and my
ten-year-old spilled this big bucket of
popcorn oh and I and I was like I looked
at it and I was like and my friend was
like well pick it up
and the weird thing is is like
I was like I was gonna pick it up but I
was like he thought I wasn't gonna pick
it up
and so I was like but why wouldn't I
pick it up because I think the tendency
is like someone else would do it oh yeah
right times have changed man I noticed
when the elevator stops people get out
people will get in before you even had a
chance to get out that never used to be
the case
wow well here's an interesting thing
that I think is happening
usually when I'm out and about and I
used to and I'd run into somebody and
they'd be like hey nice to meet you we'd
have a nice conversation then at the end
they used to say hey can I have a photo
or I don't want to bother you can have a
photo now they say you have this nice
conversation they we trained for a while
and then they go hey can you call a
friend of mine yeah and I'm like what do
you mean and they're like if you could
call my nephew and I'm like
no
yeah and these are perfectly normal
people yeah
and
and I'll be like no I'm not gonna do
that and they're like calling your
friend I just you know I just want
people to know yeah it's too much dude
yeah somebody the other day was like Hey
Brother uh this is the craziest thing I
ever got this guy
is a young Mexican guy and he had on a
wife beater right and he's like hey will
you sign my jersey right that's what he
called it which made me laugh first of
all it was really funny and you seemed
like a funny dude we had a nice chat and
then he goes hey homie will you make a
video for my cousin Hector right he's
like like what's wrong with yeah sure I
will what do you want me to say like
just say something nice man he got
possessed by ghosts that's what he said
right
and the guy's being totally serious
so I'm like what do I even [__] what
do you want me to do sorry you're
possessed by ghosts yeah so I was just I
was like what do you want me to say like
just tell him we miss him you know
so that's what I did I was like Hey
Hector Homie we miss you dog
but it was just like what are we doing
yeah what's the value here you know
what's the value like what
what onions are we growing right that's
the overall question here um you have a
new TV series that's out too right yeah
dude you're doing a lot of acting do you
think that's where you're gonna start
directing more do you think no no but I
hope to act I you know I hope to act and
I love stand up and and since Philip
Seymour Hoffman died you could take over
his stuff I mean everyone keeps saying
that why
um it is like one of those things where
part of me when people say that I just
think that's weirdly common that people
say that and the other part of me is
like why aren't I getting those roles
Capote too or something
it is kind of funny man sometimes
people's brains fill in the other person
you know
um Dan um who would play you
oh I don't know probably
um
there's this
if five doctors this kid named Rupp
he's like I don't know what show he was
on but he's interesting DJ Rupp bring
him up
he would play me I think
kid
but get him more re let's just see if
see any more pictures of him we thought
what's the dreads from I'm not sure
yeah these are old pictures of them but
um I think he would probably play me I
think I could see him doing it yeah I
don't know where is he from I'm not sure
probably
is he is he a DJ I don't know if he
really is but he's funny dude
he's this dude is really really funny
but I think he could probably play me
who would play you you think say you'd
die you passed away oh my god
um who's the guy who um oh I knew it is
Jesse Pemberton Jesse plemons Jesse
plemons yeah he's cool yeah did you ever
meet him
I've never met him I met Phil Hoffman a
couple times you did yeah did he say Hey
you look like me a little no I mean yeah
I think we both had heard it
and I we improvised a movie
where um
with a bunch of other people and
um they were figuring out it was this uh
Bob Balaban Who does these other things
and it was it was a great gig like I was
flown to L.A to improvise this movie
every day and all this and this was in
the
maybe 2000s and um
or maybe maybe it was before that and so
anyway
um
so we're sitting there talking and so
I'm with Phil and I go
I go well we should probably play
Brothers
and the guy's like I was thinking more
of you guys are friends and I'm like all
right I mean we literally look like
brothers but okay and so
yeah that guy's weird no vision then no
but he he's obviously Bob baliban's
brilliant but oh he's a brilliant guy he
is a brilliant guy and he uh but like he
just that's not how he saw it but it was
and we never ended up we improvised the
script and then he Bob was going to go
away and write it and then after that
Phil Hoffman like then it was Capote and
he was on another level yeah did you
ever get to spend time oh yeah wow I
could definitely see it more and more
now yeah that's crazy I think I'm how
old was he what year was he born
what if we were born the same day if we
were found out that we were like
this that found off uh found the same
parents July 20 July 23 1967. on July
7th 1966.
what if y'all are the same person
isn't that crazy
yeah he's from the West Village no well
he was from a guy in the West Village
yeah I think he's from Rochester
Fairport New York wow where Fairport New
York did you ever spend time with um
Robin Williams
I met him a couple times yeah was he
like the one of the biggest when you met
him was he just like he was on another
level was it he was the nicest
sweetest guy like I met him at
he did uh Bob goldthwaite's movie
and he was
this really sweetheart it's really weird
because
I I you know he was known as among the
comedians
I mean there was a before he went back
to doing stand-up he was known as this
guy that would steal people's material
like some of it is I think he was on
coke and he was unaware of it and and he
talked so much that he yeah he was
Triple timing anything so yeah and so he
was um but
you know he was the sweetest and like
every time I met him I didn't feel like
I was
you know it was like talking to a
a just another comedian yeah very
strange because it wasn't like
like you know how in La everyone's kind
of looking around the room yeah
it was just a conversation he was locked
in yeah
it was pretty special like you see why
people were attracted to him yeah was he
vital or was he regular size he was he
was not he was
um
similar to Brody he he was a hairy guy
you know what I mean
what else about to answer your question
I think he was
he wasn't super tiny yeah but he was not
not 510.
do you yeah do you start to think about
it is there a spot where like a
comfortable place where comedians retire
do you ever think about that like not I
know you talk earlier about not staying
in it too long you know like is there a
comfortable place where people
I don't know I feel like I like do you
think about that at all I'm not saying
no isn't no I feel like
stand up is
a living kind of thing that
you know people might not be interested
in you doing it
uh but I think you can continue to do it
and I think that there is
something uh so emotionally rewarding
about doing it don't you feel that way
oh yeah whereas
I um but I don't think it's it's
um yeah I mean I I think that I'll it's
just kind of like coming up with new
material is just too rewarding to kind
of give up yeah there is something great
about it yeah you get one new line one
new line you're like I'm hooked for
another year right
[Music]
um
yeah I think we covered a lot of stuff
Zach do you have anything else
no I think we're all good Jim I might
have to go but okay Jim thanks so much
man sorry I didn't know we'd been here
so long no it's good it's good it's fun
I'm done
[Music]
gonna take